Uh,
you freaked bitches.
We're back at it again.
I thank the baby Jesus.
I worked my fucking volumes on.
Of course.
I've only been doing this for three
years through a laptop.
Some low tech Shit's not gonna.
Look at a circuit board that I don't
understand.
It's a simple stupid fucking mute button
and I never push it.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is what does a professional
mean?
That's like as professionals,
I get sort of kind of like the fake
professional voice,
but not really.
Um,
what brought to you by taking A.
I had a dude on my message board that
always on the mixed martial arts,
a message board that said that he went
from a 90 something dollar verizon bill
to an $18 bill with the same use.
If that's true.
That is true.
And I'm,
I'm paraphrasing the numbers.
I don't remember the exact numbers.
I should probably look it up.
I would say that that's.
He barely uses this phone if that's
true.
Well,
I don't know man.
You know,
he said was it,
was it the same use?
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know how much you would save,
but I know that I've gotten so much
positive feedback about Tang and joey's
been a loyal sprint customer forever.
10 uses the sprint backbone with ting is
is a,
it's a cell phone company.
The way they do is essentially they by
cell phone time at a,
um,
at,
at sprint and they sell it to you.
They sell it back to you,
but they do it with no contracts and
they sell like the coolest android
phones that they have.
Which part of the way did you just see
this new fucking thing that they're
going to release the facebook phone?
No,
the Samsung is going to release
something called the Galaxy Mega.
No.
Holy Shit,
dude.
It's six inches.
It's like there's two versions of it.
There's a five point eight inch and a
six point three inch.
Like what the fuck are you talking
about?
That's not a phone.
What am I going to do it?
That's,
that's,
that's a half of Joey Diaz.
Dick wanting to fit in your pocket.
We'll,
I can't.
I don't know.
It's nonsense.
That's a crazy thing.
I don't know what that is.
That's some cross crossover world thing
that you have to have a man purse to
carry that around.
Or a woman and woman would be excellent.
If I was a girl and I had a bag,
you know,
girls are allowed to carry purses,
which is so awesome.
You know,
there's one thing they have got us
whipped with this society,
not women,
but society has got us whipped with this
stupid idea that somehow or another a
man is not allowed to carry a purse.
You know,
back in the Robin Hood days,
those motherfuckers had shoulder bags.
Okay.
You're allowed to wear a backpack.
A backpack.
Like I'm a fucking schoolkid.
Nobody gives me a hard time with it,
but if I wear a fanny pack,
they will look at me like somewhere.
God Damn freaking nature.
I'll tell you folks,
we got to take back the fanny pack.
We're going to take back the fanny pack
and maybe even introduce a fucking
purse.
How about them apples?
Get yourself a purse,
boys.
Fuck it.
Yeah,
you got a little man purse.
There's nothing wrong with that man.
The idea that there's something somehow
or another feminine or weak about
carrying around
a bag is a perplexing aspect of this
society.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it doesn't make any sense.
We are allowed to carry certain bags.
If you're carrying like a military style
Duffel bag,
that's fine,
but you're not allowed to have a purse.
You can't go through the airport with a
purse.
Dudes will laugh at you.
Dudes with backpacks carrying duffle
bags will laugh at you.
If you've got a purse,
we'll give you a scar,
but it's fucking purse.
What is that?
A purse,
Bro.
You got to fucking put that difference
between the fucking person.
A backpack.
What's going on here?
Come on,
man.
A duffel bags.
Okay,
and I can't have a fucking purse.
This is nonsense.
We have subjected ourselves to some
nonsense that we just have accepted over
the years and now it's become culture.
Brian Redbank.
God bless you for breaking the mold.
Young man guys.
Zantax keeps your Zantac.
What is that context?
Is that hurt from drinking too much?
Heartburn?
Medicine.
You take heartburn.
Medicine?
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
Silly Bitch.
I'm anyway tank.
What Tim does is it allows you to,
uh,
first of all,
if you go to Rogan.ting.com,
you could save some money,
save 25 bucks off their service,
but what they allow you to do is buy
phones,
the highest end android phones and uh,
and put it on a network,
the sprint network,
but cancel whatever the fuck you want.
It's yours.
It's your phone too.
There's a lot of stupid shit that goes
along with the cell phone contracts.
And uh,
one,
one big one is the fact that if you,
you know,
you,
most people don't realize what kind of
deal they're making when they make it.
But when you cancel,
if you cancel you,
you got to pay them.
You can't just quit because you owe them
like hundreds of dollars.
It gets,
it gets fucking stupid.
And if someone is in a position where
$300 is like a make or break for the
month for them and you really want to
get out of your,
you know,
x cell phone,
eight and t,
whether it's verizon,
whenever it is you to fucking pain up
you,
you didn't really get the deal that you
got is you're paying off that phone over
a several year period or you know,
over a certain amount of time period and
they sort of add that to your bill.
So if you just decide to leave,
you didn't really get that phone for two
99.
You got a $700 phone for to 99 because
they worked it into your deal that you
pay the rest of it over time.
So that's what's going on.
That's why you can't just cancel and
things like what kinds of stupid shit is
out.
Let's just cut that out of the equation.
That's nonsense.
This complicates things.
Let's also have it so people can share
time and then spray it with.
One of the coolest things about using
the sprint network is it's not like Tang
has its own little funky network that
only works and like weird spots.
It's a,
it's a huge network that works
everywhere and the waiting has it set
up.
If you don't use all of their,
all of their bandwidth.
you know,
all of the time,
rather they'll give you a credit on your
unused service,
so if you use less than you thought you
would,
tear drops you down and credit you the
difference on your next bill.
It's beautiful.
I love it.
It's just a cool company.
I love the idea behind it.
It would suck if it turned out they were
actually evil and that they just like
the most evil company ever.
They're just doing it really
like a puppy.
Yeah.
They're all fucking devil worshipers or
some shit.
I've seen the pictures of you and your
six,
six and your tattoo.
Yeah,
we gotta talk about that picture.
Huh?
People think I'm a real devil.
Worship really silly fox.
I was at the Goddamn some Anton lavey
thing.
We'll talk about it.
Okay,
we'll talk about it.
Pull the picture up.
We'll talk about it because it's so
ridiculous.
Anyway,
Rogan Dot Tang.com.
Save yourself some money on a cool
company.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
I don't think there's any reason to have
contracts anymore.
Folks,
go there,
get your shit out,
get your freak on or whatever.
We're also brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.
Dot Com is one of our newest sponsors.
And if you buy any of Brian's desk,
squad dot TV,
kitty cats,
that is exactly how they're getting to
you.
They're getting you through stamps.com.
So,
um,
you know,
that,
uh,
Brian uses it.
It's a,
it's an easy way to,
if you have a small business and going,
taking your stuff,
whatever you're selling and bringing it
to some post office where you've got to
wait in line,
someone's going to weigh your shit and
box everything out.
It's a pain in the Dick and it's not
necessary.
Um,
and stamps.com
do it all.
They give you a scale,
um,
they,
they set you up,
you,
you print out the postage on your
computer.
I mean it's,
it's a beautiful seamless experience.
And Brian,
you enjoy it,
right?
Yeah,
it's super easy and it's just not going
to the post office is the biggest thing
because going to the post office,
I don't know how it is where you guys
live,
but in,
in Burbank it's like an hour just to get
to the cashier.
She can give him your box of tons of
stuff to send and it's a pain in the ass
here.
You just printed out and they have like,
you know,
different ways to print it out.
They have like the sticker kind where
you can print it on these stickers and
the print outs just like it's a regular
stamp or you could just put your
envelope in there and a printed right on
the envelope.
I mean,
ups.
Yeah.
No,
no,
not ups.
Oh,
so you can imagine that's it.
Not to take it to the box.
Do you remember they came up,
everybody knows that they're the biggest
drug dealer.
Mitch Hedberg is job.
No,
but that's a true story now,
which become.
That's how fucking insightful he was.
That's the truth.
I think they're getting all this weed.
Anywhere you go.
Now we've got Kelly wheat.
It's not really Kelly.
We'd people that buy it.
They got.
They got a good salesman.
I wonder if it's the same chance or
taken that you've taken with the post
office because the post office,
if you're like a drug dealer and you
sent drugs through the mail,
you don't think it's like a federal
massive with Tommy Chunk,
but it's.
Yeah,
but is it the same with ups?
No,
I don't think they're.
I think ups has a private company.
You're still doing something over state
lines,
so are still transporting.
You're still going to jail.
Transporting across state lines is one
issue,
but then there's another issue I think
is sending stuff through the post
office.
It's like they're like,
listen bitch,
you fuck with us?
Will you make us a part of your deal of
bringing illegal shit places and where
the government you can bold.
Motherfucker know.
So they,
they went after those feeds.
This is the thing in California.
I know for a fact if,
let's say you have a friend that calls
and says,
hey man,
you know,
we grew up together and everybody's out
there and Kelly will pool and listening
to Rihanna.
Send me a bag of weed and the cooking.
You do somebody a favor and get like a
vhs box,
but we sent it to him.
He'll never get those mailman.
I've had friends that said boxes got
ripped open like a dog had gotten there
with the address on the bottom.
I swear to God and they've taken out of
that.
Send it like,
what are you going to do that Hollywood
post office on Wilcox.
Don't you go in there every Filipino's
high as fuck that place.
Everybody.
Everybody's fucked up.
The trucks are crooked.
They say this is this guy.
Legit sent him a little bit of reefer
and Eddie's book and he said the fucking
thing got there.
A month later,
a month later,
I bought like the three days a month
later,
ripped open with Eddie's booking it and
they took the weed.
Eddie's book got there.
You can't leave anything to government
agencies,
man.
The Tsa.
Look,
I never complained about the TSA.
The Tsa in New York was the rudest
person,
like the way she was communicating with
people.
I ain't going to do all that.
You got.
You got to give that to this.
You got to move that over there.
I haven't used in Tuzla to lions.
He.
I'm doing talented.
JFK.
Yeah.
I was like,
this is incredible.
I and I,
I go,
you've been very hostile.
She goes,
no,
I'm not,
but I could get hostile.
And I was like,
wow.
I'm like,
people really communicate like that.
Just flippantly with people in public
that are in positions like the Tsa,
like the way she was communicating with
people but just like so short and so
curt with people and so shitty just
right off the bat is if someone was
doing something to her by having her do
her job,
that's some offensive shit man.
When people get consumed with you,
just because their job sucks.
Like I get your job sucks,
but I'm friendly.
I'll be up.
We'll we could have a nice little smile
at each other and,
and walk about,
you know,
go through this deal,
go through our time together.
It's not going to take care of the baby.
And the extra time.
Yeah,
she just got conti just right away and
it's a thing,
man,
there's a thing with people in New York
that I noticed this weekend and I dot I
forgot about,
but there's that continence,
that curtness that people have
sometimes,
but the real short with folks and folks
are shortly with each other and I'm
like,
wow,
that's interesting.
Because you know,
when that went away,
that went away after nine slash 11.
I remember always thinking that New York
was like,
there was like a certain hostility to
New York that I didn't appreciate.
I thought it was an amazing,
amazing,
amazing city.
It's so fucking crazy.
It's beautiful.
Monolithic.
I mean it's like more beautiful than the
mountains.
Really.
It's created by men when that
motherfucker is lit up at night,
it's more beautiful than even the
mountains themselves.
So I'm looking at it and I'm like,
this is like really like one of the
perfect creations by man as far as like
one of the most amazing things that
anyone's ever created and put on this
earth.
New York City's one of them,
but you can't have that many people
together.
They just get.
They get tired of each other.
They get,
they get shitty with each other.
USBS needs a warrant to open their mail,
but ups can just open to whatever the
fuck they want.
Boom.
Supersede the government were
contracting.
The La post office doesn't.
Motherfuckers don't need nothing.
They just need to whip it this nice to
see you at the window and it moves the
speed of light.
I guarantee you there's somebody at the
glass going,
check that back.
Oh,
here we go.
Look at his friend.
Anyway,
avoid all this bullshit by using
stamps.com.
Get a free scale scale.
If you.
There's a microphone in the upper right
hand corner.
If you click on that microphone,
you enter in the code j r e and that
code will take you
to the stamps.com
website where you get $110 offer and a
free digital scale.
It's a very cool service and again,
like I said,
if you order one of those desks,
quad tee shirts,
that's a.
that's how they're coming to you bitch
new shit taken to the next level.
Print new shed at home.
The interesting thing that the only
people do it or in Kennedy airport,
and I'm not angry,
I'm not saying this is bad,
let like let's say me and joe fly out
for years.
We flew out,
we made it 15 minutes before the flight.
That shit don't work.
Don't work no more.
So you and I have said,
fuck it,
we got to be that 11 will be there with
that.
Open up a computer each.
You know,
I went there and did that Kennedy one
day and they're like,
you can't go through security.
And I'm like,
you can't be serious.
Like,
no,
you can't go to,
we tell you.
So they made me an army wait where they
made me an army wait there and finally
had the sleep apnea machine and I'm
fucking hungry and if I get up at four
and six and I haven't eaten my blood
sugar goes,
fuck it up and I get dizzy.
I get that thing that,
uh,
Dana was complaining about whether
there's ear years,
I get this feeling like I gotta Puke and
I went up to Atlanta to go listen to it.
I gotta go,
I got sleep.
That's the only reason they let me
through.
Why hasn't had the machine they would
have held me there.
And I was like,
that's amazing.
I go,
well,
because they know,
you know,
I didn't eat.
I can't eat as soon as you fucking get
up,
you got to drink some water and move
around.
So what were they just hostile?
Very,
very.
That's why as soon as you said that,
I said Kennedy,
Ted Kennedy.
I didn't even know need to know.
Newark is not like that.
And look what is.
I have never had a problem in Newark.
And Laguardia Newark,
I had the problem the one time when I
took the phone up,
the moon landing and the German
guy said to shut the phone off and he
started yelling on the plane and then
when I signed the cop goes,
I don't know,
you know,
you're only away fucking team here.
This is the home team day.
You tell him to turn the phone off that
Newark.
No,
I never had a problem in Newark.
It was Kennedy and now you had it.
And I've had it twice.
Yeah,
I mean I'm pretty nice man.
I try to be as nice as I can to people
when I run into them,
you know,
from talking face to face with someone,
I'm going to try to be as nice as I can,
but there's certain times where you get
confronted with continence,
which shittiness that people have and
you're just like,
whoa dude,
you know,
fucking relaxed.
I'm saying the blow,
especially in the morning,
I don't like this shit in the morning.
I tolerated in the afternoon,
in the morning,
I can't.
I'm like,
we could do this with a couple of
servers.
And how you doing brother and everything
will be fine and we'll have a nice
little conversation here,
but you're just doing your job and I'm
just talking and we're just,
you know,
we're just two people running into each
other.
There's not,
there's not conflict,
you know,
and like there's people there that have
this hostile attitude.
They don't like making it a conflict.
I'm not here for a conflict of man.
I'm just saying hello to people.
Look at my bag.
There's nothing in it,
you know,
I'm just going to go to my destination,
take care.
Nice meeting you.
Good seeing.
And most of the time that's what I get.
Especially with the,
uh,
the,
the x ray people,
extra people or some of the coolest
motherfucker shit.
I run into those people like the dudes
that are working in security in those
areas.
They're always asking me UFC questions
and always being friendly.
I don't see them being shitty with
people.
I see a lot of them actually going out
there with.
It'd be nice to people.
So when I'm confronted with with someone
just being shitty right off the bat,
I'm like,
wow,
that wasn't necessary.
There was totally unnecessary.
I gotta be honest with you,
you and I and red band and this young
man we're blessed with.
Or have you want to call it that?
We fly a lot.
Yeah.
I know that the recent conditions after
nine slash 11 have stopped a lot of
regular people.
They don't like it no more.
I gotta be honest with you.
A couple of weeks ago you had people on
here and I know you tsa.
I have no problem with them.
I've had a problem with.
It's not easy either.
You go to them and your plane's going to
fucking blow up that fucking simple.
Okay.
And when you know that we've met people,
that situations have happened,
they've gotten through the line and
realized they had a fucking bazooka on
their luggage.
You know,
that always scares the shit out of me.
Bullets.
Yeah.
A friend of ours with the bullet,
you know,
that happens.
But I ain't never had a confrontation
with them.
I've had confrontation.
You know,
people on the line.
Sometimes are the worst people you have
real slow when you go.
That's my case.
Like I had a problem and fucking someone
vegas flying out one morning with some
fucking guy that was 80 like,
fuck you.
Are you fucking serious?
Uh,
but no,
no,
no.
I,
I've never had a problem with those two
years at all at all.
It feels so weird.
Then I do everything as they told me,
the belt comes off your sweetheart,
you a fucking case.
I take the tube,
I leave my vapor pen and I confused them
with that.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
That's a lady I've never had a problem
with.
But uh,
that,
that particular,
you know,
you got to go to JFK.
You did,
you got it did sucks.
It's unfortunate.
I mean it was only a couple of people,
but it was just like,
it was more than one.
I was like,
wow,
this is nuts.
I'm just trying to be nice,
you know?
Would you have a move to New York?
I thought about it.
I always think about it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's kind of an interesting situation.
We'll talk about it after we get done
with.
Oh fuck.
Fuck all the commercials,
man.
I don't want to do any more commercials.
All right.
Dot,
come to the last one.
O n n I t you don't know what it is.
Go Fuck yourself at this point.
Seriously.
Best commercial ever.
Uh,
what it is.
Shit that's good for your brain and odd
weightlifting equipment.
Uh,
one of the coolest things that we have
now is the champ with the chimp
Kettlebell that has the expression I
like to describe the biting your Dick
off face.
So if you see that that chimp Kettlebell
data is the look that chimp would have
right as it's biting your Dick off.
And think about that while you work out
with it and we'll give you some extra
motivation and some extra strength after
a horrible car.
Fire.
Oh Dude,
that's so rude.
That's a chimp son.
Scariest fucking prime minister.
The planet.
And we're just lucky they haven't
figured out how to use guns yet.
It's crazy.
Fox trying to keep these things alive.
Look at that meet and looking asshole.
Crazy smart ass hole that can kill you
with his hands.
Yeah.
Why don't we have more of those?
It should be just running through the
streets.
Oh my God.
What we do without them,
what we do.
Without them,
we'd eat the bananas.
That's what the fuck we do.
What's wrong with you?
Chimps?
Everywhere.
What's that?
You see that tiger up here yesterday.
The Mountain Lion Yang.
Glendale.
Fucking what do.
There's a lot of mountain lions lately.
We're always angel,
Lindale right by a New York Park when
they call it.
I don't know what part of Glendale was,
but that's not an immediate to be seeing
that as the only way you get with her.
I'll fucking immediate release one of
those fucking leopards was this mountain
line in the back of a white car driving
down the street.
You know it give us.
They shot it on a porch.
Second shot it on someone's porch.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's who need a mountain lion
Kettlebell.
Just to give you.
Just say you're fucking working out like
that thing's going after the hardest
domesticated.
Oh,
it's impossible.
You can't get them as a kitten.
Yeah.
He never can really domesticate them.
They never really domesticate wild
animals.
You train them and there's a big
difference is that dogs are dogs,
man.
They've.
They've been dark for so long.
Like you know,
like,
like my dogs.
They're super friendly dogs,
man.
I never worried about them being mean to
me.
I don't worry about weirdness.
I don't worry about them just flipping
one day and ripping my throat out.
But with a lion or something like that,
that can happen.
Mountain lions don't.
You don't,
you don't own them.
Bitch.
That is straight den.
A killing,
straight killing millions and millions
and millions of years.
Nothing but killing.
That's all.
It knows so much.
Diane Sawyer and I see a bear wrestling
little line.
Is that real?
He could be,
yeah.
I mean people have done shit like that.
Like a monkey choking the bear,
like hitting him in the face with left
jabs.
They can do that.
How come I can't train?
They train them.
They can see that one this week or with
somebody.
It was a mountain fucking bad.
Big.
They say about something,
it was a leopard,
a fucking bear,
and then a third wild,
like something that was so obscure like
a beef,
uh,
like they're all playing and chasing a
ball together.
What we need,
we definitely need a mountain lion
kettlebell.
That's for California.
They have a mountain lion problems in
California.
I sold you.
I saw,
I went to Santa Barbara last week.
How big?
It was big,
I mean big enough to kill you for sure.
It was like coyote size,
my fucking pants.
It wasn't as big as the big ones.
You know,
they get up to like 200 pounds I guess,
but it was probably like 70 or 80
pounds.
It looked like a coyote.
It was moving across the road and y'all
coyote is like stiff,
but mountain lions like bounce.
They have like a bouncer and I just
assumed it was a coyote because it seems
wild animal running across the road.
But then I see its tail and then put it
together because you're looking at it,
you know,
it's a flash glimpse as it runs across
your headlights.
But it was probably about,
you know,
70 pounds that,
that,
that'll kill you.
Dental fucking killed this shit Eddie.
I'm going to tell you was killing
motherfuckers that snow in Colorado.
They take into deep April off.
That's why Jack Nicholson snap,
that's why in that movie that you could
tolerate November,
December,
January.
That's cool too.
But now you're out of the weeds,
you know,
St Paddy's Day.
You're like fuck it.
Put away the boots march.
And they dumped.
Well how many inches have they gotten?
A big blizzard though.
Forty inches so often a month for the
month.
In total.
I'm talking about they just locked the
airport Wednesday,
didn't they?
Yeah,
they didn't come on.
Was tweeting about getting stuck there?
No,
they don't.
That's why you can,
that's a great place to live.
If you got a fly in April,
April,
you have a pool going,
the guys over putting chlorine in and
all of a sudden I seen people with
facebooking pictures.
The light lights with six or seven
inches.
The whole town.
White April.
Two different kind of living.
Different kinds of living.
You,
you're dealing with nature on a
completely different level than what is
so pussified here in California,
but we've got mountain lions pitch,
we've got mountain lions and they're
moving in.
There's been more of um,
I mean,
come on,
this is not,
this is not a one time situation.
They shot one in Santa Monica last year
and then you've got this one in
Glendale.
They're moving into urban neighborhoods.
They found one in my Monica last summer.
We have podcasts.
We discussed,
found one in a gore.
I'm recently out near Gora.
They have their,
they're seeing them all over the place
now.
What is the reason why they're coming
down into the cities?
Well,
there's two things going on.
I mean,
I don't want to be ignorant about this.
Stephen now will be on the podcast
on Monday,
the hunter from that media to show and
he'll be able to explain to us a little
bit better,
but I think there's been plenty of
music,
man.
Let's fucking,
let's do this actual podcast is
ridiculous on a.com
o n n I t use a codename on the podcast.
Here we are,
but we're not.
It's crazy.
I'm the audio,
the audio version,
so it's always the podcast.
Amazing experience.
I just realized that I'm asleep
doing a podcast with that stupid song.
What fucking difference does it match
what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
And now it's the podcast.
What am I doing?
What am I crazy?
But the podcast just began a fucking
half an hour ago.
We don't need to play that Goddamn song.
Yeah.
The thing about mountain lions,
Joey,
Joey Diaz is in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
for the people we need to stop editing
this thing to just fucking accept it.
Serious can edit it.
Everybody else can go fuck themselves.
And that's really all that's happening,
right?
It's just a series.
It's editing the first part of the
commercials out,
but during the commercials,
sometimes the best shit we say,
sorry.
So if you listen to this on serious,
he got to go,
uh,
go to itunes.
Maybe we should just mix the commercials
in our woods,
pull out like a cell phone.
I'm like,
Damn.
It makes it like fake.
Hey Brian,
what is that cell phone you have in your
hands and what?
Tell me about ting.
We should just do it once for fun.
What?
Uh,
the,
the issue with the mountain lions where
they're seeing more of them.
There's one of them that cut a
tranquilized yesterday in Glendale.
We're talking about this.
I saw one last week in Santa Barbara and
uh,
of course there was the big one in Santa
Monica that they killed,
which I think was about a year ago,
but they're not using dogs.
The hunt them anymore in California.
They changed the regulations and when
you changed the regulations,
you're going to have more mountain
lions,
like it's still legal to hunt mountain
lions because they're trying to keep the
population under control.
But by not allowing hunters,
these dogs hunter say that's the most
effective way to kill mountain lions and
still incredibly difficult.
What kind of dogs?
They use hounds.
They use hunting dogs and they,
these specially trained dogs are
designed to go find mountain lions.
They find mountain lions and they treat
them and then the hunter shoots him and
that's almost the only way to catch
these fucking things.
Okay.
Because they are in the woods.
When you talk to me about an
intelligence like nature intelligence,
their way fucking smarter than you,
they know what,
they're not going to get below you.
They're going to stay above you.
They know that it's harder to run uphill
and downhill.
The the like,
they have like instinctual things that
you as a city person that's wandering
through the woods,
you don't know what the fuck is going
on.
You know you,
you literally need dogs to find them
because they're too fast.
They're just going to.
They're going to hear you walk in and
they're gonna be like,
bitch,
get the fuck out of their cats.
Their big giant cats that are living in
the woods.
Can we have this weird attachment,
you know,
to like certain aspects of what
shouldn't,
shouldn't be legal when it comes
managing
the wildlife around us.
But you got to be really fucking careful
about allowing predators to take hold.
I mean you gotta be really careful
because right now we're fine,
but if the balance can shift and you
start getting to know Australia
crocodile situation where this place is
in Australia,
you can't fucking go because if you go
you will get eaten by crocodiles.
Like they will come and they will
fucking get you and there's too many of
them and you know,
you just,
you just areas of the water,
you can't go there.
If you go there,
you're going to get God.
It's just gonna happen.
I don't find that acceptable.
I just don't find that acceptable.
I think the idea behind it is
ridiculous.
Ninety percent of everything that's ever
existed as extinct 90 fucking present.
I don't think there'd be any problem.
We can't bear the crocodiles.
I mean it would be kind of cool to keep
them around and look at,
but if it had to do with like crocodiles
overpopulating and starting to fucking
kill people,
you can't.
You can't think about them as being like
one of us.
they are part of nature now.
That's a monster.
Godzilla mountain lions.
That's the wolf man,
might as well get,
I mean for mental health and gets you
with the wolf man gets you.
It's the same shit you just got got late
night,
night night bitch.
One of those big cats gets you to shit.
Fuck cheese.
That's a monster.
That's a God damn monster.
It's a mountain lion and we are working
so hard to conserve and protect these
killers,
these things that need to kill every
day.
These monsters that run faster than us,
jump higher than us and only killed
things with their face.
That's all they do and they can kill you
and even if you have a knife,
it could still probably kill you.
Even if you have two knives,
they'd probably kill you.
Even if you're trained.
They don't give a fuck.
Kill you.
That first lunch that they go that rips
a limb,
that'll you fucking.
What do you call that vein?
That starts bleeding?
Cook,
rotted artery,
and they hit it from every angle,
from every angle,
the way they swabbed it.
You don't get something done.
You're done.
And I'll tell you what,
listen,
you know what?
The biggest animal I ever saw in boulder
was a snake.
Really right off hill road.
I never seen nothing like that.
Well,
those yellow motherfuckers coiled like
this thick.
What kind of snake was it?
I stopped and asked him.
You know,
I asked him where he was from.
I think it was like fucking died.
Someone's like pat that they let out,
I don't know and the most likes on my
father in laws property and he was.
I was like,
what the fuck?
We had to pull over and apparently
that's the thing they have a real issue
with in Florida.
People just take pythons but like this
thing do big fuck this.
They just throw it out.
Fucking white people.
Crazy white people in Florida,
man,
I got me a pass on it.
Won't see the rabbit.
Come on to feed my sheep,
feed my snake rabbit.
And then all of a sudden you realize
you've got a rabbit eating monster
living in your house and one day it
wraps around your arm and won't let go.
And you're like,
alright,
I gotta get rid of this thing.
It's 18 feet long down to the fucking
swamp and just go,
go be free.
My friend.
I didn't want to take it and kill it.
I mean I knew it was thinking about
killing me,
but it's my pet.
I had a connection to it so I just let
it loose in the swamp.
I saw a homeless person walking down the
street with a snake around his neck,
like a big one too.
Was his pet homeless?
Got Snakes?
Scariest thing ever.
Yeah.
Rap or roles.
Weird man.
There's A.
There's a weird thing with reptiles
because they don't give a fuck about
you.
They never give a fuck about you.
They're just conditioned to maybe do or
not bite you to bite you or not,
but you.
Hm?
What should I do?
They have to think about it,
but they might just decide to fucking
bite you.
But if you feed them and if you keep
feeding them,
you stay with them and you,
you,
you become this connection to food for
them.
They'll accept you,
but if you die,
they're not going to cry.
They don't give a flying fuck about you,
and if they were hungry and they thought
they could eat you,
of course they would eat you.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter how long you've been
feeding them.
You got a 20 foot long python,
your house bitch,
you're living in his house.
Okay,
will you are you are his little slave
and you are bringing him offerings.
That's King Kong.
That thing is tied to a fucking pole.
That's a monster and if as long as you
keep feeding it,
maybe it'll let you come close me.
Maybe where you got it in your backyard.
What are you doing there?
You got to go cage back there.
You crazy.
Fuck.
I can't deal with it.
So they can't even kill him,
man.
I can't go to Sally's house and see him.
Give like a white fucking mouse to
think.
Especially when I'm high.
My fucking hands.
I've seen it.
I've seen people say come over.
Oh yeah.
I've seen.
I had a friend.
That's why I don't like it,
but man,
that's fucking creeped out for me.
I don't know.
It's completely creeped out.
I Dunno.
They're terrifying animals and those
motherfuckers were the snakes walk
outside with the snakes around that
head.
It's those motherfuckers and bird on her
shoulder,
which makes me want to not understand
like especially like a parakeet or
something on you.
And I sit there and I get so high
sometimes I get a fucking eagle just
like I never see that.
I would love to see something like that,
like some jerk off doing magic tricks
with the fucking parakeet on this show.
One of those fucking birds are just come
swooping on fucking bird and the fucking
Iraq.
There's a great video of a hawk.
The comes into an eagle's nest to try to
get the Hawke's Bay.
The Eagles babies and the eagle just
goes wham.
Grabs it and eats it in front and starts
feeding into the baby's wow.
Fucking crazy.
An Eagle just flies into this.
Hawk.
Hawk rather just flies into this eagle's
nest.
Wow.
It's crazy.
I know that there was a guy on it.
Watch this.
There's eagles just chilling,
covering it's babies and this hawk is
like Gimme,
Gimme,
Gimme your babies and
the eagle just like bitch don't do to
others.
America kills it on top of his babies.
Look at this.
Wow.
Are Her babies rather?
I'm sure that's a Mama,
right?
Only the mamas are the ones who guard
the nes,
I believe.
I don't know though.
But look,
fucks up that Hawk and eats it.
Yeah.
They caught that on an eagle camera
because they have a nest camera to
monitor these birds.
But what a creepy world.
So the Eagle is the meanest one.
Other the baddest,
most Hollywood.
Did you ever see it?
No.
No,
no.
No.
What's in Hollywood?
My friend hawks.
Okay.
The Hawk,
he has um,
vista right next to all those streets.
What we used to curse on El Compadre,
he's him and his wife put cameras
because they would wake up in the
morning and see dead pigeons or
something.
They couldn't figure out what it was.
And one day they got to have Keith.
Okay.
Yeah.
The picture of a fucking,
a pigeon landing.
And then this thing coming behind it.
Grabbing it and ripping his fucking head
off like a monster.
Just ripped his head off and started
eating it without the fucking head right
there on Vista,
on sunset.
I went to the Museum of natural history
and tremendous.
And the two of you,
you know,
you get to see.
It's amazing,
amazing the thing hanging the waylon
top.
Oh,
it's still there.
The dinosaurs alone.
That means it's gigantic skeletons.
They have incredible place,
but they showed the,
uh,
the transition between the dinosaur and
bird and you know,
that's,
that's a dinosaur.
Like it's.
They explained the whole thing,
like the dinosaurs that survived became
birds.
When you see an eagle,
that crazy country monster that
represents our country,
like what a perfect thing to represent
our country.
Like we always thought.
I always thought the eagles proud.
Eagles.
Both the Eagle is a county monster from
the past.
That somehow or another I managed to
stay alive and as long as you keep
giving it birds,
it'll let you fucking hold it.
It's only.
The thing about eagles is they're not
quite big enough to kill us.
They're not quite big enough.
You know,
I'm a kill and Eagle man.
I'll probably get fucked up a little
bit.
I'll get scratched up a bit,
but if I get ahold of an eagle,
I'm going to kill that fucking thing.
Take the finger off,
right.
Probably fucked me up pretty bad.
I'll probably be cut up pretty hard,
but I'm going to win.
I'm going to kill that fucking eagle and
he knows it.
He knows it.
He looks at it and go,
damn,
I wish I could kill you,
but you just tell a little too big
because then he goes only like 50 pounds
or something.
Right.
You know,
they looked.
I mean they're pretty fucking scary and
they,
like I said,
they will fucking hurt you,
but most likely they're not going to be
able to take you out,
but they've tried to pick up kids and
shit.
Eagles have picked up a little boys
before.
I tried to fly off with him is a matter
of fact.
There's a video of an eagle picking up a
kid that's a fake video.
Is it a fake video?
I've been just students.
Son's a pitcher.
He was not going to suddenly scared to
check out.
Like I see a chicken dog and I panic
like I'm scared of the chickens.
Chickens moving.
I fucking panic at all.
I could go into one of those butcher
shops with animals,
those Italian,
like margiela and the east coast.
You ever go to those places where your
mom goes in Newark and they have the
fucking Italian butcher going in and
have everything.
Like all those birds.
What's the whale?
Then they'll have like a chicken and the
other thing.
Then they get exotic.
You go do they serve as well?
You Go,
you know people are into eating like
shit,
like ego still,
but this is the place where you could
stick your hand in and the guy would
take the chicken out and break its neck,
cut it,
and then your mother brings him home for
Cte,
like pheasants,
maybe all that shit.
I mean,
in the old days they probably had like
polar bears.
Don't give a fuck.
What are you gonna?
Need an alligator.
We got it.
Just give me 15 more.
Currently there's a company that will
serve you like Ryan stakes.
Yeah,
there's like,
yeah,
they're like,
it's some sort of exotic game meat
company and they'll,
they'll sell you lying.
You can eat lion and Colorado is known
for that Shit.
Restaurants could blue next whether
you're taking 12.
We discussed this where they take you,
they pick you meet up at the top of
snowmass village and they take you there
and those things that the dogs,
they take you over a mountain,
you your wife,
they put blankets on you.
It has to be in the winter.
This is real shit.
They pick you up at 5:30
sharp.
You get there,
you'd come out and you get all the
alligator fucking a dinosaur dinosaur.
Fucking Puerto Rican meat.
Take a fucking rat.
It's amazing.
I saw it.
I never went there.
I knew the guy that had the dogs that
would whip the fucking dogs and shit
over there,
so we had like a sweater,
one of those,
but I know that if you fly into China,
Hong Kong,
don't quote me on which continent.
There's a restaurant that just
specializes in testicles.
Jesus.
Did you see that shit?
Every type of attack,
there's one that belongs to a fucking
Allah.
It's a stamp and that's the big one that
comes with a soup.
It's like a testicle soup.
I think it's like $18 for the fucking
suit.
Oh my God.
I'll look it up.
It's disgusting.
But,
um,
making sure people pay the Animal Dick.
That's fucking crazy.
That.
How funny is that?
Even real life.
Like your mom killed somebody in front
of you,
like your ego comes in real life.
I was like,
eat your Broccoli.
I don't like Broccoli.
You Bam.
Bam.
What's that?
Oh my goodness.
Cat.
Oh my God.
They're all eating a cat.
Holy Shit.
Oh my God,
Dude.
That is a creepy,
creepy animal.
It's really.
It just pulled the meat away from its
babies by the way.
One of them was like,
that is mine.
Well,
it's been,
it's been like taking it apart and
feeding and I've been watching for
awhile.
It's really cute watching.
Have you ever seen the video of the
wolves are getting killed by the eagles?
Yeah,
guys have trained eagles.
You got to see this.
I think it's a mongols or is that a
motorcycle gang?
They're uh,
they have a trained eagles,
golden eagles
that a swooped down and uh,
and kill wolves.
I guess Golden Eagles are even bigger
than,
than a bald eagles.
I think I should look it up.
Let me look that up.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's big because the size of that
thing and look how it does this.
And the dude is all like done up and
like tribal traditional,
like animal skin clothes.
I mean,
he's in a harsh,
harsh world and he's got this eagle.
These got trained and this.
That's a bad motherfucker.
Watch this shit.
Yo.
It goes after a fucking wolf man.
I mean,
what a gangster bird.
That's mean.
You want to talk about that?
That's like the wolf is like almost the
top of the food chain.
It probably thinks it is the top of the
food chain.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Bird knows what a terrifying feeling
that must be to be a Goddamn wolf and
still be scared of this evil bird.
Look how it takes it out.
It just swoops down and grabs the bull
by the back of the neck and just starts
jacking it.
Don't you think though,
this wolf could easily just fucking
attack this bird?
No,
you would think,
but I think the birds are stronger than
you think they,
they're,
they're really primitive man.
I mean,
they're not like we look at them like
they're all fluffy and shit,
but you look at their musculature and
the way they're designed,
they're not designed like any other
animal.
We sort of associate their size with the
way we would view like a mammal that was
that size.
Like,
oh,
that's not that big a deal.
Like if,
uh,
you know,
whatever.
A puppy or something in or a dog rather,
that was that big was trying to go
after.
You think that a dog that's only 60
pounds,
it's not going to be able to kill you.
That what kind of.
That's a Golden Eagle now that I've.
They killed that.
That thing would have claw.
Yeah.
Could the claw and the neck and then
they,
they tear him apart.
I mean their claws are unbelievably
strong and there's essentially knives.
They have like knives on there,
they're huge arms do.
They can pick up a fucking salmon that's
swimming in a river.
Stop and think about that for a moment.
How strong you have to be to grab a
salmon with your hands.
You're a big guy.
Joey.
Do you think you could grab a salmon?
Do you think you could hold onto a
salmon?
There's no fucking way.
How about grab it and then fly off with
it?
Do you know how fucking strong egos have
to be?
That's an evil ancient animal that we're
like,
it's the noble proud.
Here you go.
Remember,
uh,
that guy that sang those songs,
the guy that John Ashcroft let the
eagles soar.
Did you ever hear that song?
Did you ever hear that song when
Ashcroft was the,
what is the attorney general or
something like that.
Whatever made up fucking title.
It was whatever.
Job Distinction.
Yet he was working for the Bush
administration,
whatever function they in,
and he was completely crazy.
It was just nutty Christian guy and he
had the most amazing song that he sang
once.
And when he,
when he's saying,
and everybody knew right away,
like,
Whoa,
this guy is fucking nuts.
I mean,
we knew he was nuts,
but what the fuck is this worth the like
she's never saw before.
And he said,
yeah,
it's.
I mean it's,
it's,
you're watching madness,
you're watching 100 percent pure,
unfiltered madness.
And you just watching it.
All you think of is what kind of twisted
shit is this guy doing when he's not
doing this?
Because if you're that far out there,
you're that far out there that you're
seeing that the ego will,
you know,
and you're like,
it was like super,
super duper Christian.
Like that guy had some fucking bones in
his yard,
man.
Or do you think Wolverine Versus Wolf?
Who would win if I had a guest pull up
that left the eagles?
Soar.
Got,
I need to hear that.
But what's a wolverine?
Um,
I would say a wolverine is a,
it's like a Badger,
Badger,
Badger family.
And there were fierce,
unbelievably fierce animals.
They're crazy looking to.
They look bad ass,
man.
It's like hugh grant.
He does.
It doesn't make sense.
They call him wolverine because the
whole idea of wolverine is wolverine was
supposed to be built like Sean Sherk and
was like a small guy,
but he had these crazy muscles and he
had like this adamantium skeleton.
You had like some metal skeleton,
but it was like a little like fierce
thick guy,
but then you have the.
The guy plays him.
What's his name man?
The dude who plays,
what does it?
Hugh Jackman,
which I know.
I just said it isn't.
I like them to whatever.
I blamed the weed,
but Hugh Jackman is like this beautiful,
tall,
handsome,
you know,
like statuesque sort of male model
looking dude.
It's not really.
It doesn't work for like that character.
The character is supposed to be like a
wolverine and Wolverine's like and
that's what this guy was like.
He was like,
this hairy dude with his hands would
turn into these sorts.
Like they would come out,
these giant knives come out where his
knuckles are and he would just fuck
people up.
It was one of the most ruthless
superheroes ever.
When you think about it,
I mean because he would just kill people
all the time for the comic book.
Oh,
I fucking love the x man,
man.
Listen to this day.
She's never before.
That's a real sign.
I don't know why it's got the cow bell
and the cowboy.
The cowbell socks.
This like,
that was a cow bell thing going on
the Internet for awhile.
That's crazy person it a crazy person.
Crazy person with black socks that
stinky feet,
sweaty feet all the time.
And leather shoes.
Just wanting to get weird one that stick
his thumb up.
Your Butt fucking choke you or something
bro.
With Jay z going to Cuba.
I don't know man.
I don't know.
I saw it in
the news you see that you saw on the
news was what was hilarious was that the
uh,
the people in the news,
we're looking at it as a political
liability for President Obama that Jay Z
is,
you know,
going to Cuba.
Then it weakens the,
the Obama position.
Like he can't,
he can't be friends with Jay z now to
my.
And I was watching it.
I was like,
wow,
this is weird.
This is like they've managed to turn the
White House into the real housewives of
Orange County.
Literally have managed to turn the White
House until like almost a,
a bit of a reality show.
Like,
oh,
what is,
what is Obama going to do about Jay z
Bnq?
But oh,
that's crazy.
That's a really important thing to think
about right now because it's not like
there's a country called North Korea
that as weapons and it's threatening to
shoot at us and has nuclear capability.
Yeah,
man,
what about that wrapper?
That guy who makes stuff?
Ryan,
why did he go to that place where
everyone's poor?
What the fuck?
I just seen the headline from Atlanta
Vanna,
something like that.
I'm like,
oh,
this is terrible.
It's so weird how right now in today's
world,
the White House is really what's going
on around.
It is a reality show compared to what's
really going on.
The wife is on Conan O'brien jumping up
and down credible whatever,
and I ain't got nothing but love for.
I love that woman,
but do you understand me?
I mean it's all different.
Like it's like the government is pushing
that shit at you to worry about that.
While we're really,
really going on right now,
it's fucking scary whether it's Korea,
whether it's going on.
Oh,
well one good thing.
The post office ain't gonna fucking
clothes now that you see that close on
Saturday,
starting in November for mail delivery
on Saturday.
No more mail on Saturday.
November.
But no,
they just changed on the Monday.
They found Jesus.
Somebody opened their mouth and so are
you fucking serious?
I get my copy of my fucking time street.
Whatever the fuck it is magazine.
I,
you know,
I really wondered whether or not we
would be better off with a privatization
and that,
you know,
because I think ups does an awesome job.
I mean they're,
they're amazing.
And the,
the postal service,
the only issues that I've ever had with
the postal service is going to the,
the actual place to the actual place and
waiting in line.
That's the only issue that I've ever
had.
But the idea that you should have a
government company that does what
private companies do,
like why would you even need it?
You know,
why would you need a,
why do you need a post office?
Why do you need,
you know,
[inaudible] shit.
I mean,
the post office as,
as it exists is great but shouldn't
exist because,
uh,
of the market because it's like,
you know,
it fills a spot,
you know what I mean?
Like why should it be,
why should it be the government that
does that?
That's what it was.
One of the weird questions that are
signing.
In an ideal world,
it would be great if the government did
all that stuff right?
In an ideal world it'd be great if we
could trust everybody to handle
everything,
but it seems like everything gets
handled best when it gets treated.
Like it's a business,
you know?
And when,
whenever you have like government
organizations that are taking places
that could be taken place by business,
you sort of like,
you're controlling things and regulating
things.
I mean obviously in the post office it
works great,
but it doesn't work great in the DMV,
right?
It doesn't work great in the TSA.
It doesn't work.
There's a lot of places where it doesn't
work great.
Sure.
Jonathan winters died.
Yeah,
I heard sex.
Why is it,
you know,
I,
I hate to bring this up and keep going
with this,
but why is it that like the post office
had all those shootings.
What,
what happened there?
Just because the workers were
overworked.
I mean if you look at if you go to the
post office back in the day because it
doesn't happen anymore,
like the shootings don't have anymore.
I,
I don't know why it's not happening
anymore,
but there was a time like if you go to
the post office now and you just look at
the people that are working there,
that looks like the most miserable job
ever.
They're just sitting there nonstop from
eight in the morning,
but he just used stamps.com,
lightened the load and then there would
be less work and everybody could show
the fuck out.
Yeah.
You imagine that's a thankless job man.
I didn't even check my mail and like I
don't check my mail except maybe once a
month now and it's like the worst idea
in the rub because I'll,
I'll check it and there's like all these
bills and like late payments and stuff,
but I hate the mail so much that now it
literally,
it's like a stack this big of mail once
a month and only about five percent of
it is something that I need you to pick
up the mail it gets delivered to you now
have a huge mailbox.
They just,
they just,
I mean it's right in front of my house.
I just don't even care.
I just.
Okay.
So the post office is completely a
government Gig,
right?
I think it is.
Yeah.
My uh,
I have a friend back home.
My friend Adam,
who's a postman,
he's been a postman forever.
He used to work out with them at the
Boston Athletic Club,
like back in the day and he's like,
he was like a real neighborhood postman.
He would like go door to door,
knew everybody.
Said Hi.
They would like give them tips for like
Christmas and stuff.
It was like a real neighborhood postman.
Do they still have those?
Yeah,
some places still have like a real.
A guy who was like,
how you doing?
Good morning.
Like knows everybody
now is a dick.
But the guy,
the guy hadn't Hollywood,
he was a Filipino and they gamble.
So I owned them.
He delivered to me first.
He knew if I.
I would tell them don't.
I'm getting a check this week.
Stopped by here first and I'd see him
like at night he'd give me the check
early and shit.
Good guy.
Still seeing him.
He's still down.
I wonder if
so how those guys feel about things like
stamps.com.
I mean they still have to deliver things
so you know what I mean?
It's not affecting them.
That's actually probably make.
Yeah.
It's probably like a lightening the load
a little bit.
Guys love their fucking job.
That's a great job.
You're walking,
especially in California with the mail.
People hate more than fucking we do is
the ship they have to deliver.
That's why a lot of them.
See I'm talking to you from the other
end.
I did time with three dudes that dumped
the fucking circulars,
so if a mailman dumped circulars,
they go,
what are you talking about?
Oh,
well you gotta think from routes.
It says grapefruit,
three for ninety nine cents.
Spam spam in your mailbox.
I know male guys that have done time,
like I knew a fucking hippie in the
coolest motherfucker ever.
Tenge coolest white dude.
I loved them from fucking some white
investment in Oklahoma.
I loved long hair.
He used to be fucked with them,
put it in a ponytail.
This motherfucker filled this garage,
I don't know,
for 10 years with the spam and something
happened at his house.
He had a fire in the backyard and they
found 10 years on boarding the fucking
on it.
No,
he didn't want to mail it to people.
We thought it was fucking terrible,
but he had a do as part of his job.
They threw him in fucking jail.
Oh,
they throw in jail because he didn't
send it out.
Yes.
Those.
Because he didn't want to spam them.
Yeah.
He didn't know.
He liked the people in his neighborhood
and these people got together and they
got his little legal defenses down like
two grants,
two years in time.
He did federal time and then I met other
guys a diagnostic who were cool mailman
who just,
that's the big beef and my one of the
kids I grew up with them.
I'm very tight with filter this day got
fired and he tells hysterical like he
used to take the little car into the
city to go to the RTB.
Right.
And he'd go pick up grandma,
blowing a little mail cart and go back
over the Jersey over the bridge and he
throw the mail away.
He would tell me how the whole place
was.
He got fired before he got caught
because all their phones.
And listen to this.
This is 20 years ago,
so here you go.
You ready for this bomb?
They had him on tape 20 years ago.
Gambling on the post office phone.
Oh Wow.
They been listening on the phone before
nine slash 11.
The act of [inaudible] 66 that we all
buy into.
So they just recording agency since
1950.
They've been taping everything when you
call home and tell your husband going to
go home and suck his dick.
Got It on tape.
You know what I'm saying?
It's hysterical.
They called them in and play the tape.
That's hilarious.
So this data,
we said,
well,
one of the day investigating the
bookmakers.
No,
we weren't calling them and making my
shift ends of the 12 come.
No one's ever done a movie about
wild-ass mailman
because some crazy mailman stealing shit
and finding like some check and figure
shit they find they fucks.
Probably live checks to say.
I mean like they walk around,
there's like these girls that are at
home by themselves,
you know these,
these,
these wives that you know and they
probably know that the mailman,
right?
Skanks you can make it happen.
Oh,
and do me a favor before you tough guys
or the right ones for you.
Tough guys.
Touch your mailman.
Touch him.
Getting to be for your mail mail one
time.
Oh,
this is a federal employee.
Yeah.
Tell your mailman one time.
Hey,
fuck off.
If you're going to come over here,
don't fucking hit the gate because my
baby say that the middle man one time
and see what happens to you,
but how about don't say that because let
me tell you something.
Within 15 minutes you have a police car,
your house,
and then you'll have another fucking
employee,
some car that you've never seen before.
And they fucking.
I had a friend that either mail man with
a Frisbee.
Oh No.
And I was only,
they were doing that shit and the guy
cut across and hit them with a Frisbee
and they laughed.
So the guy thought it was done.
Intentionally brought this guy,
did a year in fucking jail duty.
Fucking assault charge.
Touching a fucking mailman.
But in both at one time.
This is an interesting story.
In the boulder,
there was a guy that got bit by a dog.
So now his phobia,
he hated dogs,
but he needed the job as a mailman.
So if you left your dog in the yard,
he would spray your dog shit to your
face.
So one woman was home one day,
he heard the dog,
you know the dogs outside and seeing the
mailman's fucking sprang and some she
told the neighbors some other dog had
died in that route and the guy waited
from this [inaudible] 90 no.
80 six in boulder.
Guy Waited for the mailman.
Next Day,
took him to the fucking boldly you to be
careful,
bro.
They took him in that fucking backyard.
Him and his brother and a beat on this
fucking guy.
I think one of them went to jail.
The other boulders are fucking crazy
place like that.
When you don't know who you're messing
with.
People.
Colorado are the descendants of old
cowboys.
I mean you gotta think like back
generations.
He imagined fucking mailman up.
I come in.
Well they did in goodfellas.
Well,
if a guy killed your dog,
you know that you love,
you might.
You might be willing to do a little
time.
You know,
there's some pieces of shit out there,
man.
There's some pieces of shit.
It'll kill your dog.
Fucking poison.
They don't care.
I have a friend who moved to a place,
he had a Barky dog,
so I'm poisoned his dog,
you know,
I mean,
that's a crazy shit man.
You know,
I mean,
I can understand that you ever have a
problem with it.
It sucks.
It sucks it.
Some guy has a barky dog,
but poisoning the dog is crazy.
I mean,
and not only that,
it was,
it was a big area.
He lived in like a,
a big rural area.
So his dog wasn't even on leash like
because his dog was allowed to roam
free,
but apparently people didn't like it
that this new dog live in the
neighborhood and start barking.
So they just poisoned it,
you know,
that's just.
I hate when people,
uh,
get defined in life has been like an
animal lover or not.
I mean everybody's an animal lover.
We're all,
we're all lovers of animals that you can
trust,
you know,
and when you meet a person and they have
a cool dog,
like,
you know,
a friendly person by their friendly
dogs,
you know.
So like the idea that you could do that
to spray dogs and the fence.
Yeah,
that's like a sociopathic sort of thing.
That little dog do you have.
It's not even real.
It's not even real man.
Is Your dogs.
Your dogs don't even really marked for
his first time last night for days.
And did you come?
No,
no he didn't.
He,
I have mirrors in my bedroom,
like I'm on the doors and he just sits
there and stares at Adam self because he
doesn't understand.
Verus,
and finally last night he went crazy on
the mirrors and just barked his first
time it was.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
He's so cute,
man.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah,
I found something.
I've been cleaning out my office.
Uh,
I found something the other day and it
completely opened up like,
like a memory that I completely forgot
about
when I was younger.
And this is so crazy.
I can't believe I forgot this.
We used to have this thing called time
and temperature.
Do you guys remember?
Do you guys have where you live?
Where you called a phone number?
Like the time?
Is the temperature?
Remember that?
Well,
the sense a call,
your mother will almost fucking kill
you.
I didn't know that,
80 bucks and fucking time and I got a
fucking collapsed all over the house.
I remember that when I was a kid I had a
calling card and if I didn't know the
time I could use my calling card and a
fucking phone booth and call and get the
time and temperature that wants to put
his.
That
the one in Ohio was free I think and it
was just a phone number you call it.
But what happened is,
is at one point something broke where
like anyone else that was calling could
talk to the other people listening.
So it became a chat room for like three
months.
You would call time and temperature and
suddenly here like,
hello,
are you there?
Anyone there?
And you're like,
yeah,
I'm here.
How are you know,
like you start talking to people.
So I met this girl on top on time and
temperature and I got her phone number
and then we started talking for like two
weeks and she said she went to a
different school and all this stuff and
then she was a virgin and she was like,
I will pay you $100 if you sleep with
me.
And I was like,
yes,
I will take that money.
I was 17,
I was like $100.
That's amazing.
So she,
I was kinda scared of how she looked and
everything like that.
She came over to my.
I was when I lived with my mom and my
mom was out of town.
She came over one weekend,
never met this girl,
just talk to her a few times on the
phone that are on time and temperature.
She comes over and she was like a lot
older,
like I'm 17.
She was probably like 30 and I was like
alright.
And she.
But she acted like she was in high
school the whole time and I just was
like,
I guess she's in high school,
but like I knew,
I knew that she was older,
like,
and then she wrote me a check with her
name on it and I was like,
oh you have a checkbook or wow,
that's cool.
Like I was 17,
I didn't have a,
but she could write checks and I fucked
her and I've now looking back at it.
I never even thought about it.
She was totally an older chick that was
fucking younger guys.
Like she,
I was underage and she paid me.
I was a hooker at 17.
That was time and whether one of and
pick up kids because kids can kids.
Only kids were doing it.
Like I remember like this was like a
chat line for kids and I will be like,
oh,
what's going on?
Yeah,
Worthington.
So she was just some crazy freak bitch.
It was fucking 17 year olds.
Yeah,
meeting.
I'm on time and temperature.
That's amazing.
But then she know you were 17.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I said I went to high school.
She said she went to this other high
school that was like 20 minutes away.
It's possible that she just did a lot of
meth.
A.
Honestly,
when she first came over I was like,
oh my God,
I'm in trouble.
This is the person's mom.
But then she was the girl and then she
like,
we didn't barely talk.
I remember she walked in and we talk for
a second.
I just turned off the lights in my
living room.
We fucked on the floor and she gave me a
check and she left.
It wasn't like in and out half hours,
but you spend the money.
It took a while to cash a check because
I didn't have a,
a checking account and so I had to like,
I think I had to like get a cashier at a
grocery store or something.
But yeah,
I spent the money.
It's great.
I totally forgot about it though.
Wouldn't it be an amazing reality show
to follow that woman around?
Like if you could go back in time and
just watch how she did it in the age of
no Internet,
just fine young guys and meet them
somewhere and just fuck them and pay
him.
Actually Pam,
like how crazy was that chick?
Do you think she was that crazy?
Or maybe it was just like a one time
thing where she just lost her mind and
got caught up in the thrill of the
moment.
Yeah.
I have no idea,
man.
Think about how creepy that movies.
Because again,
how do we make one of the payphone at
the bottom of the stairs at the comedy
store and watch the checks coming in and
out of the bathroom.
Will you guys do is way out of why the
telephone when somebody's going to be
drunk and somebody should have never
taken down that painful history.
Oh my God.
They should put a payphone back there.
They should find a payphone.
Yeah.
They took it down and they also took the
wind down at the Improv that used to be
outside of it.
They shouldn't do that,
but you know it's still there at the
comedy store is where like all the guy
comics come in and they tilt the the
window so it's like perfectly.
So you can go to the stairs outside and
just sit there and look down and see any
girls in the bathroom.
Oh,
that's so gross.
That's so gross.
That's so fun.
That's why whenever I like my girls are
like,
that's really illegal.
You shouldn't even really be talking
about that on the phone or on the
podcast.
Allegedly.
I've never done it.
Really creepy.
Sitting down by the phone waiting for
fucking pictures to coat the.
If you're a girl.
No Shit.
That's disgusting.
Piece of shit.
That's a.
that's a terrible human being.
And you're like thinking it's all silly
there.
Run your foot.
Jamie Kilstein would be yelling at you
right now.
Crying out rape culture.
Say that.
I've noticed they do that.
Yeah,
and I could probably tell you someone
should fucking black that out,
man.
You just call them.
Call the manager and they have to do.
Now they're going to have to.
By the way,
you just fucked it up.
We've all done things,
but that's one of the fucking life.
You're not gonna be able to pull that
off anymore because you talked about on
the podcast and the comedy store's going
to have to fix that or they'll be
liable.
It's funny because every time you have
to let them know,
man,
if you let go in there,
you better let them know for real
because people are going to talk about
it in the pocket.
That's a big issue,
man.
You're.
You're making it out like it's not a big
issue,
but looking in on girls like fixing of a
mirror or a window to look into girls
while they shit.
That's like a seriously against the law
and seriously creepy.
Yeah,
I agree,
but you're just joking around about it.
I'm saying that every time I have a
girl,
I'm with a girl and she goes to the
bathroom.
That's the one thing I say,
make sure those things are shut when you
go in there.
Blind things stuff.
Well,
I mean if you go in there as a girl
though and you see it,
it's obvious like,
all right,
there's an open window right here.
I should shut this.
That shit's ridiculous.
It shouldn't be there.
It shouldn't be like that.
Girls shouldn't have to be,
especially in a place where they're
serving alcohol.
The last thing that should have to
happen as a girl should have to worry
about who could
possibly looking through a window while
she shitting.
Yeah,
that's nonsense.
That's complete nonsense.
Fix that.
You just eat edibles.
Careful.
You're a dangerous man.
Champions going to be jamming.
These edibles are potent shit.
Sterile cap at the whole bag it 130 that
this fucking thing.
Okay.
Uh,
it's like a tootsie roll.
Fucking kill you.
It's amazing.
By next year in California that's going
to be like zombies.
They will be zombies because they're
going to double this.
This is for fucking loads.
They're going to double this.
Don't,
don't say it.
Don't say that.
People are going to be walking around
with shirts ripped open
zombies and shit and that is fucking
crib.
You know,
we've all had the,
I don't know,
I don't know.
I don't remember looking through the
peephole over that.
You don't know,
just,
it was just fucking crazy shit that you
try to think of all the crazy women that
I met through that over the years and
the different situations.
It's fucking crazy.
You could write a book and it's kind of
disgusting.
Oh,
the comedy story saying disgusting.
You know what the,
the beautiful thing about the comedy
store was the comradery between
contracts,
like we all sit in that back and hang
out.
That was a,
there was so much camaraderie and that
guess still is.
Yeah.
It's like having an employee meeting
with,
uh,
your,
your peers every night.
And it's,
it was,
uh,
it was so loosely regulated.
You know,
it's getting more tighter now,
unfortunately.
Well,
we kind of have to do that.
It should have probably been tighter a
long time ago,
but the real issue was always,
you know,
how do you,
how do you run a club and run a business
and then still sort of let the comedians
do whatever the fuck they want.
Sometimes it doesn't work out.
Comedians wreck your blades,
you know,
that's why I always try to contribute to
that place as much as I could.
Like is like I would do it for free.
I paid for the sound system there.
It's like,
what?
You need to go back there and pay for
any sentences.
No,
that's bullshit.
I'm sure it has a sound system.
I bought in like 2001 or some shit,
you know,
it's an old sound.
So it's scary there too because I do the
show up in the belly room and,
and uh,
up in the belly room is like falling
apart like you,
like I went to plug something in and
like all the electricity went out and
then I'm like,
these,
these outlets are not legal.
Like this is impossible.
Like you would like,
I'll turn on,
light
them under the bus boy,
keep it up,
keep it up.
You're like,
fuck you.
There's gonna be people that are
thinking big conspiracy.
Well,
what I know is the Joe Rogan had a
problem with us.
Next thing,
his little bitch,
Brian Rad.
He's just talking about the lines about
our security staff with some of the
finest in Los Angeles.
Okay.
I handpick them myself.
Fucking thing blew up.
But things from 1920 people.
She's dead.
Oh fuck.
See,
I have nothing but love.
Got One foot in the grave.
One of banana peel that she's very.
She's very unhealthy.
But I love that.
Have never had any,
any issue with her.
But I'm talking about the building that
it's funny watching it.
Nope.
There's no maintenance man walking
around in the daytime looking at the
fucking uh,
the plugs attention.
I don't know about.
She didn't want to lift a rock for 18
years ago.
That motherfucker must be leaking like a
motherfucker.
That thing that it's didn't want to go.
Remember she got Bob Baker up.
They're putting this back on.
That motherfucker made a coke and
fucking black tar and all that shit.
Fucking roof of your building.
You a fucking problem.
Fuck no fucking jumped off a roof.
Fucking.
It's fucking California.
It's 80 degrees outside.
Fuck Bob Baker.
Fucking Bob Baker putting.
Fuck.
Come on up.
Help me.
You fucking crazy.
I'm gonna.
Fall under that roof.
I got nobody that suit.
Do you remember when the guys were
launching water balloons from talking
about that the other day?
Yeah,
whatever was there.
There was like.
That was about seven years ago.
Steve Reynolds.
Easy.
Hey,
it was.
Who the fuck are you talking about?
Jesus Christ.
Son T,
you need to go to a doctor.
I swear to God.
Five years before someone who's shy
right now.
We can't tell the story.
I heard the story five years before I
got there.
When Tupac shot the gun in there.
Oh,
it was all a black club.
They used to have metal detectors at the
door in 95.
I never saw that.
I was there.
I was there in [inaudible] 94.
It wasn't like that.
They would just have like fat Tuesday's.
We get crazy.
The one that Eddie Griffin was saying
one night,
Tupac Lynn,
and then they had to shoot out and
everybody ran.
Mitzi bandom because she thought it was
him.
In fact,
the bullets are still on the front room.
I'm one of the things still yet to fuck.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't doubt that.
There is some crazy shit that went down
there because they,
they did have some crazy shit happen
there.
Even like Kennison shot a gun in that
place.
He,
there's a hole in the backside and that
came from kinisons gun.
It's still there.
The whole still there.
It's kind of fucking cool.
You know,
just to be around a place for Camp Sam
Kinison last shot.
A hole in a fucking sign.
I think it was about dice tip.
Was it?
Yeah.
I think we should have asked him about
how he did.
My memory is done.
You know,
it's crazy.
My memories.
It's filled no room.
I'm taking it too much information
lately.
It's crazy.
At 30 years from now,
you know,
and they know they're going to call and
say somebody you often 10 million for
that property.
Oh the store.
Anything.
Any day somebody is going to break and
go,
you know what the fuck,
let's buy that side.
This side.
The side across the street.
Well you know,
it's worth a lot of money.
Worth a lot of history of that place.
It's just under history is on the fire.
But.
But some John Deere fireball,
some Japanese group,
we don't give a fuck about her.
It's true.
It's going to show up with 60 mil,
but an underground casino in there.
Whatever the fuck they do because all
those streets haunted and you know what?
We're going to be driving by that he is
going to come because it's.
It's.
It's impossible to pull something like
that off today.
Is someone willing to gamble that much
money today?
Or is this a tricky economy?
I don't know.
Every time you go to vegas,
every time you go to vegas,
aren't they building a new fact?
Somebody is talking to somebody telling
them that the future is bright.
You gotta be bright.
You know what it also is to.
They just adjust.
Like instead of making 10 billion,
okay,
we're making five.
We call,
we call with five,
let's be cool with 5 billion and they
just cut it in half and they're.
They take a loss.
All those guys have something that's
losing though that fucking angle to
write off and have a good time.
But to take that place down,
it would be so sad.
Every place has gone down.
Even fucking Arnold's went down on happy
days.
You know what I'm saying?
It was arnold's fucking real.
It was real enough.
But they shoot,
they fucking take everything the fuck
down and that's,
you know,
that's the reality of it.
It's so weird.
I don't even go to that side of the
sunset.
I know how I drive by it and I feel
guilty.
When I had my ear infection I had to go
to Canada to go get a hearing test and I
drove past and there was amazing.
I'm like,
when was the last time I drove on
bucking sunset when you and I used to
hang out there between like was it like,
I think like 98,
97,
2005.
I was in
Kinda wish you guys would hang out with
us one day to me,
Don Barris and all of us,
Tony Inches,
all just sitting in the back shooting
the shit,
smoking too much weed
back.
Seeing the same people who were in
charge back then during the men steal
stele incident.
They're still in charge.
They're the only person there is one
person,
people,
man,
that angle of it is forgotten.
I take it from a different angle.
That was then.
This is.
No,
there's nothing I could do to bring that
back.
Why don't I?
Why don't I go home,
get my football jacket and put it on.
It ain't got in front of my high school.
The improv has never been anything but
cool to me know they're very proud of
them.
All of them were great and on top of
that,
I mean there's also the laugh factory.
Jamie Masada is a wacky dude.
Nice final month and then there's the
fucking ice house,
which is the greatest club in the world.
That's my back yard.
I don't even need to go anywhere else.
I'm fucking hobbyist out.
The thing
cool though,
is that all of you,
like if you guys were to come last night
on the patio as an example,
you guys would have been like,
oh my God,
there's like 30 people here that I know
all in one big group.
What?
I mean,
everyone's got their dogs now and it's
amazing place.
I'm going to hit you from a different
angle.
This is the angle I like that.
I remember being up there and being 30,
seeing old guys going,
what the fuck I gotta hear this story
when he was here.
He,
you know,
I'm so insecure when it comes to that.
Joe.
I saw Carlin there.
Dude Carlin hung out.
That was one night.
I know.
What I'm saying is,
you know those guys that become that.
All of a sudden I don't want to be
there,
but you know,
this guy's like dom irrera.
He'll stop in.
He just bangs out.
Is set.
Hangs out a little bit.
Dama Breira is one of the coolest
motherfuckers that guy is.
He's like a real stand up.
You know,
like when you got the weekend with him
and did you say this?
You guys are working together one
weekend together at the Ice House.
The last week.
It's for shows crush.
You don't like the building on fire once
in the.
It's going to implode.
Let me tell you something.
Dom irrera is one of the most underrated
headliners ever.
That's my take on him.
I.
That guy is when he's on when dominant,
like I did that show with him at the
factory and he was on.
Dude,
he's fucking brilliant.
Hilarious.
The shit that he comes up with the and
he constantly rights.
He's constantly writing.
He's constantly like looking at the
news,
coming up with new shit.
I've heard two beautiful jokes the last
six months.
That a brilliant.
The one joke was the one my boy said on
the Oscars when he said that.
Right now the show's being viewed by 2
billion people.
That's why God is going to come up here
and ask you about her privacy.
Something like that.
That's a well written Joe Damo rabbit
athletic joke.
That's a great job.
That is one of the best jokes I haven't
heard in a long time since your island,
Nicole.
That is one.
Save the fucking that athletic athletic
neighborhood.
It is such a fuck.
And you know,
say the joke.
I don't want to.
I don't want to say it.
You got to see it.
What do you get a chance to see this?
Because you guys are what?
Where is this that you guys are gonna
work together the last week of July,
like the four shows.
Oh my God,
we've got putting shows Friday to
Saturday and I'm honored because you
know what?
After I've been watching them that that
Wednesday night he's got at the laugh
factory is when you really get the seat
down.
That's it.
He's in the catcher seat.
His legs,
I think it's Tuesday,
right?
What's in it?
Busting balls with Donald Wednesday too.
He does.
He does more than one show there.
It's going to take a look no matter who
he got there sometimes,
and I don't like to say that sometimes
he's got and you'll understand what I'm
saying,
Joe.
Sometimes he's got a comic on there that
doesn't shine and the social avenue of
comedy sometimes some people just so
introverted.
Go Watch them with those people.
He brings it to life and he's brilliant.
He turns around and Bob so friendly.
It's easy to easy to banter back and
forth.
When they called me and asked me,
I said,
yeah,
why not?
I just watched.
Now I want somebody for four shows and I
got a different flavor.
It's very tough to learn from somebody
when you watch 10 minutes sets in La,
La me doesn't give people come out and
I'm not discouraging people coming out
and going,
oh,
I'm going to Joe Rogan.
Excuse me,
at the comedy store.
That's a 20 minute set.
At least sometime sit tight.
We'll get there.
But to see a 10 minute dominant wherever
tartar,
45 minute damn Rara yeah.
It's two different fucking people.
Yeah.
It's,
I think it's that way with you as well.
Uh,
you know,
I think it's that way with anybody.
You know,
I've seen you do 10 minutes.
That's not what I want to see you do a
half hour.
I want to see you do 40.
I think at a certain point in time I'm
done.
You know,
I'm,
I'm cool.
If someone wants to do 50 minutes of
hard shit,
you know,
I don't mind.
I don't mind that,
but I really like a long set.
Like when you get into a guy and he
started laughing at is stuff you want to
keep laughing,
you know,
you want to keep,
you want to keep going,
you want them to keep going.
Like a norton.
I saw Norton in Austin and he had like a
50 minute set.
I was like,
wow,
that's like a,
that's like almost like a perfect time
because he had like two guys go on
before him and he fucking devastated for
50 minutes and then after the 15 minutes
was over,
it's like you felt like perfect.
Like it was.
He just nailed it.
He blast.
It's like an episode of game of thrones.
It's about 50 minutes,
you know,
it's not really an hour.
It's like,
just blast you with hilarious shit and
then you're like,
that was great.
It was like the perfect amount.
There's just like a balance.
They're trying to find the perfect
amount.
How much is too much?
How much?
A little too little.
But those 10 minutes are always a
little.
It's hard.
It's not bad for you.
No,
no,
no.
I love it.
I love going to the local places doing
15 or something just to get out of the
fucking house.
I was at the last two nights and I had a
blast.
I went to to like,
I went through my spot orange and packed
with that squad people.
People brought pictures of chimps I'm
sure.
Had a fucking sandwich.
Bach and he believed the sandwiches.
I've told you about this place before
and then last night I went to a place.
No,
amber,
this place was on fucking fire bucket.
Was somebody on a balcony?
Oh No.
Fuck it outside.
Outside on the third floor.
Wow.
It's like the second night they did it
like once a month.
Who was with you?
By myself.
They call me.
Like yesterday we had a four.
I was that.
What was that?
Like?
Tremendous 30 minutes.
I was home by 1130 and it's all people
coming out to see you.
Mixed.
Mixed,
you know,
like local guys put together and Shit.
It's amazing that some weeks I stayed
home and some ways I go this week I'm
going out five nights just to feel what
that's like and I'll do five nights with
the Friday being the highlight of the
joke.
Now I'll take Saturday off.
I'm home or something.
I stayed home with whatever the fuck,
you know what I'm saying?
Some nights I like doing that.
Some weeks,
Tuesday night did something really cool.
I did red sting.
Oh,
the storyteller show at the theater with
the comedy central and it was,
it was good to see her brother.
That was his baby.
You know what I'm saying?
He's filling in for comedy central now.
So it was when he called me,
he was embarrassed about what does this.
I don't care if it goes on comedy
central Dot Com.
Okay.
Have a fucking embarrassed.
You know,
I could just see.
He was like,
he thought it.
He thought he was gonna.
Call me like what?
Carnegie Hall Gig.
Know what I'm saying?
And it was beautiful job.
If they're going to put it on comedy
central and we'll get a lot of years to
see that.
He put this together,
this was,
he had two sets work that,
you know,
the camera he had makeup on.
He wasn't neurotic Jew.
He wasn't mumbling.
Ari's legit.
Now he is very
bridget
and it's really weird to see a guy that
really paid his dues.
I saw him when we got to the store,
he would sit back there like a nerdy
motherfucker with that hair cut one day,
bust out with like 90 percent
commercials and the whole time he was
going out and
fucking everything and we got
hemorrhoids in his ass.
Remember this shit the size of a finger
we started taking on the road was like,
wow.
What year was it?
That early.
Let me start taking 2005.
I'm sorry.
It was way earlier.
Yeah,
way later than that.
No,
I think.
I think it was before 2006 because I
remember it was a Mike Young,
couldn't make a Gig and Ari came instead
of her and yeah,
in Denver and he fucking destroyed and
he was only doing comedy a few years
back then,
you know,
but to,
to him,
like I said,
I think it was probably the biggest
crowd he'd ever had and then like his
development from then on really a lot of
it was like going up in front of these
giant crowds.
Like he went from like open mics to like
doing these sold out gigs and in between
he would do the store,
you know,
and are we went like in front of our
eyes from being like a guy just starting
out to being like a fucking legit
headline that I would go see.
Like if I was in like say if I lived in
a town,
if I lived in Utah or some shit like
that and it was going to wiseguys I
would go see are like that.
Like I'm a comedy fan.
I would,
I would go see that.
And that's,
it's,
it's crazy to watch.
It's crazy to watch crazy.
It's crazy to watch it happen to
Youtube,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's in Dunkin as well.
It's crazy how much it means to me now,
like in the early when
I was here didn't mean to me enough now
like,
no,
I have to sit down and write it out.
I have to really think about it.
I have to think about my thoughts.
I've been thinking about because I don't
want people to be disappointed,
you know?
I don't want to write material that's
bad for me.
I want it to be,
you know.
Right.
You have been my thing and
responsibility.
I'm the same way.
I want to do 50 minutes,
an hour when I'm going to be out.
I want to smoke dope and drink some
fucking water,
whatever.
I,
I just,
uh,
it's been a real pleasure lately.
It's been a real.
The whole twitter,
the whole writing.
It really has fucking made me sharp.
The podcasting,
the fucking podcast and gets to a
different level now.
Yeah.
We got on here now.
I can listen to a podcast now for 15
minutes and I can tell what's good and
bad.
It's radio wish.
When we do a podcast,
they tap into a conversation.
It's like walking in,
sitting down and going,
I'm right here,
my sandwich,
and next thing you know,
you just listening and learning.
Well,
it's like they get to see you in the
most real estate environment
possible.
Like the the most surreal you possible
like I don't feel represented by and
things at 140 characters.
Like when I write things on twitter,
a lot of times I run.
I'm like,
oh,
how's that going to be conveyed?
You know what I mean?
It's only 140 characters.
When you.
When I hear you say something,
I know exactly what you're saying.
I know where it's coming from anew.
Your inflection,
your pause,
the seriousness in your voice,
the intensity in your tone,
whenever,
whatever it is.
I know what you're saying.
It's hard to express yourself on
twitter,
but on the podcast,
that's where people grow to love human.
Then they see.
They hear that voice on twitter when
they read your tweets,
they know you,
they know your voice.
I mean,
you know who you are,
so they see that in your twenties.
Then it works.
But it's a lot of things on twitter,
like people,
people.
I had an issue this week or um,
uh,
people,
I've had a few,
but uh,
people keep getting upset at things that
are right on twitter that I think are
pretty obvious jokes.
Yeah.
They kind of Douchey,
like kind of like I said about something
about male vegans.
I said,
uh,
if you're a male,
if you call yourself a male Vegan,
I hope you choked.
No,
not male vegans.
Excuse me.
Male feminists.
I said that if you call yourself a male
feminist,
I hope you choke to death on Vegan
Pizza,
like crying to a lady Gaga Song.
Okay.
I'm just joking.
All right.
We fucking lax.
I'm 140 characters.
When you say something like that,
people like,
oh,
he hates all male feminists or
feminists,
or he's a chauvinist or something like
that.
It's like,
no,
but let's be honest.
How many guys that you talked to that
are male feminists are really annoying?
How many?
It's most of them.
Most guys who are male feminists are
really annoying.
Well,
there's been a few.
There's what?
Listen,
the ideals behind it,
nothing wrong with it.
The ideal.
We get some more of those corvette
things and some of the cocoa cafes.
Man,
those are the shit.
Yeah,
I have a cookbook cafe,
but this,
um,
the tweet,
I just,
first of all,
it all started out.
I got pissed off and I talked about this
a little bit on the ice house
chronicles.
So there was some lady that was saying
nasty shit about kids like didn't like
kids and started wrote on twitter that I
view women who don't like kids the same
way I view dogs that like to eat,
throwing shit.
Like that's how I look at him.
Like,
Oh,
what is that?
You know,
it was just,
it was just being a fly on the wall
during a shitty conversation.
Right?
So I write that down on twitter and then
people get angry at me.
Like you're equating women too.
Shit,
eating dogs.
And No,
not exactly.
I mean yes and not exactly what I'm
basically saying is it's kind of a gross
thing when someone doesn't like kids and
that's what I was feeling at the time,
but I didn't know.
I probably shouldn't have wrote women.
I probably should've wrote men.
I didn't think about it because it was
actually a woman who was doing it and I
always like it when I see women that
like kids especially because I have kids
and women that like kids are like cute
to the kids and it's kind of fun.
But I should've said people and not,
you know,
men or women and I should have probably
said hate instead of not like.
Because people were saying,
oh,
like if women don't want to have
children and they're pieces of shit that
had nothing to do with it.
What I meant,
I don't care if a woman doesn't want to
have kids,
you should absolutely be able to do
whatever you want to do.
And I could totally understand not
wanting to take on the responsibility of
kids.
If you're a woman.
That's not what I'm saying.
I don't mean doesn't want to have one.
What I meant was doesn't like them.
That's it.
Like people don't like to like fucking
kids away from me.
That's creepy.
It irks me.
It irks me with anybody,
with men or women.
But I saw a woman it.
So I tweeted about that.
Then I started getting all these white
knight feminists dudes that were giving
me a hard time.
I'm like,
man,
you weak bitches.
You better shut your mouth.
He's silly.
Fuck.
So it was just like over and over again,
this nonsense about,
you know,
this,
this contributes to violence against
women and your attitudes or misogynistic
and like,
well I'm talking about someone who
doesn't like kids.
That's it.
That's all I'm saying.
You know,
and I'm standing in 140 characters and
maybe it's like,
it's just a stupid way to say anything
controversial.
You know,
maybe twitter if you don't want to be
misunderstood.
And if you don't want to have to explain
yourself,
don't say anything controversial,
you know,
because anything.
Because people look easy because it's
such a limited form of expression.
They can all of a sudden imply all sorts
of meaning to it and then write,
hold blogs about this implied meaning
they all of a sudden have like this
whole cause and all they're doing is
misinterpreting an original statement,
but because it's so narrow and its
definition,
because it's only 140 characters,
there's so much room for them
bullshitting and coming up with their
own meaning and now.
So it's good because like,
I had a bunch of feminists write blogs
about me.
It was hilarious,
like reading all this,
like my massage mystic attitudes and
this and that,
like that's about as far from the truth
as I hope,
you know,
I always try to be as,
as open to everybody as possible.
I like being a man,
but uh,
I don't have any problem with anybody
just because they're a woman.
I think that's completely ridiculous.
I think though that there's a lot of
fuckery in this world,
man.
And there's a,
there's a lot of people that are full of
shit on both sides of the fence.
Hail Satan,
that Hail Satan thing.
Yeah,
that's A.
Duncan had this thing he did for her
wedding and Tom Lava,
that internal event and that's it,
right?
Yeah.
And he was uh,
he asked me to,
uh,
do a devil horns and where his tee shirt
and look at the,
take a picture.
It was a cool wedding and music was
played there with a.
what's that guy?
The Hank Williams.
The third one?
Yeah.
I didn't get to meet the other guy
wanted to meet him because I love the
wonderful white to West Virginia.
But anyway,
you know,
he goes,
well you wear my shirt and do the devil
horns.
Were like,
yeah,
fuck it dude.
I'll do it.
And then I got all these people.
St Joe Rogan is a satanist that is for
real.
That is the dumbest form of Satan is
like you really thinking that,
that satanism me standing there with a,
a tribute.
What does it say?
Attribute to what
a tribute to six,
six,
whatever.
What you're also saying,
your tattoos have satanic things and
I've been seeing a lot of crazy things
lately where it's like your left arm I
think has like some kind of a satanic
snake on it or something.
Fucking dragon to represent my ferocious
spirit son.
Shame of people don't.
People will take the time to acknowledge
that shit and can
blow it up,
you know,
but also no,
shut up.
Right.
But it's also people on both ends,
like you choosing to get upset about
some really ridiculous should read a
tweet and you go to that person's paid
and you go,
I get it.
Once I read some tweet and I go to their
main page,
I can put.
I can add up right in one minute ago.
I get it.
I get where he was coming from.
I understand why you said that.
He's a musician.
He's Dad,
he's a politician.
He sells this.
He likes.
Like today somebody hit me and I ran.
He was a poor riser fan.
I get it.
You're a fucking book.
You know what I'm saying?
I've never met a poor riser fan,
so if you shoot yourself in the fucking
mouth right now,
you want somebody.
If I go to some of these pains and I see
like music and I know the music sucks,
that's where it ends because of his
choice and music sucks.
That's what if I don't see fucking one
of my three on that,
like I'm going to go into people's.
There's two things.
I judge people.
I don't judge people by money and not
legit people.
That music collection.
If I look at your collection and you
don't have sabbath paranoid if you don't
have the staples Zeplin too.
Those are the staples Zeplin to why
we're here.
Why are you?
Why are you wasting my fucking time?
I'm over here.
You got like 30 grand.
You know what I'm saying?
That's.
And number two,
when you open up some of these
refrigerated,
there's certain.
Yeah,
it's true.
You Open.
That tells me everything.
If you're a fucking move,
if you're a month,
if I see like low and beer,
your fucking ain't never coming in and
there's certain people that they have
music laying around just because it's
cool,
but tons of them.
That's why the generation of people that
want to say,
and I know this and I don't hate you
because I'm kind of in the same way that
they don't want to like floyd.
They prefer to listen to,
oh,
that's so commercialize that into more
receipt.
You know,
that make me feel bad.
The worst being the Tom Waits era,
those motherfuckers are ones I want to
punch him right in the fucking face
because they're the ones.
You're having a good time listening to
something.
You're bobbing and they want to like
really impress like some fucking dumped
check with fractals and southern.
Everybody's fucked already.
Don't know what I'm saying.
Everybody fucked.
All you need is Tequila and a gram of
blown she'll be sucking your dick in the
fucking bathroom.
You want to be cool and let Tom Weigh
heavy weight.
That's good.
Second,
you want that.
You're a fucking idiot,
but the only reason that people would
put that shit on is to try to overpower
you with that fucking star wars.
What do you call that?
The fucking thing with the mind.
Generous.
That's it.
Oh,
he's so.
Oh my God.
He likes to listen to that.
They're trying to let me sit you down
with a gun next to your head.
You're telling me.
That's good.
Fucking second.
Beatles.
Y'All fucking shoot.
You can put a gun to your bucket.
All right.
Telling me that's good music.
You fucking 20 years old.
Not at all.
Like when somebody says,
I like the Dave Matthews band.
I will pistol whip you with.
You have satellite on the way up here.
Says to me they wouldn't do an accident
by Bob Marley.
I almost crashed out a white dude with
no shoes on.
A black new planner.
If fucking it's too.
It's too made up.
Uncle Joey stop it.
I think he's got some good songs.
Dave Matthews got a few good,
so hopefully she got me emotional.
Fuck this shit.
I was too quiet over there.
I hate all that shit.
You don't like to just move over.
I can't stand fucking time with and the
people like Tom Waits,
look at them and go to that page and
it'll tell you the whole thing like
that.
That something ain't right,
that vegans something.
Then,
you know,
stop the pill.
Pilgrims they care for something that
you're like,
really?
I always like to.
Tom Waits is a guy who probably has a
song that I would like,
but I don't want to go find it.
Oh,
it's probably like one or two songs.
One Song.
Pick a fucking song,
pick a song.
And it sounds like he's taking a shit.
It sounds like a dude.
What the fuck is this?
More on singing and I know people going,
oh my God,
he's a revolution.
And I know Paul Mccartney.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Why?
He's alive.
Everybody else was dead.
Paul Mccartney won this war.
That's true.
Joe Harris is dead.
Everybody's dead.
Michael Jackson's dead dead.
Paul Mccartney still,
even his wife,
he killed the fucking.
Blew the Lipton chick.
What did her parents own?
Fucking Kodak Shit,
man.
When he moved to,
he didn't know.
He drove it again,
a fucking sandwich.
He died in a car.
Remember dog,
nobody.
Fuck.
Then he had the one with the missing
leg.
Courtney lives one.
This fucking game.
We beat out one.
Everybody's McCartney outlived
everybody.
The only one.
Him,
Elton John Bowlby,
Mick Jagger.
Which you don't even want to fuck with
all those other guys think Mick
Jagger's.
Filthy motherfucker ain't today.
God,
I hate that motherfucker.
Just look at them.
You want to just wrangle mcjagger.
Why Mick Jagger's a different dudes.
You know Mick Jagger,
Mick Jagger.
What was his background?
I don't know.
Like look at his background,
his background.
He went to like the best business
school.
You know that really?
Yeah.
In England.
Like he's like a fucking wizard
economist or something.
This story.
Yeah.
He don't do nothing unless you show up
with a big bag book.
I know in Boulder,
I,
we talking about this in the podcast one
time in boulder,
you know,
out in conscious the seats behind you
shot him,
but Mr Jagger,
nobody sells the tickets behind them.
They won't mind.
I'm Mick Jagger,
those tickets so we don't go on stage.
You heard that new shit.
It's horrible.
You sound that bad.
That new songs,
not the enemy.
It's not that.
And why would you put up?
Let me see where I can find it.
Let's help them.
Let's promote the rolling stones.
How funny is that?
Yeah.
It will help you out.
Rolling Stones.
I know you need this.
You never read the little podcast.
He's got a book.
He's got a book that somebody wrote
about them and they interview somebody.
Who's the chick that's in?
You know you're so vain.
Carly Simon.
Carly Simon sat next to.
She was awesome at some movie premiere
or something.
Make Jack sat next to him was like,
dog.
You gotta join.
No,
you got a quaint little.
You got a bump of coke.
No,
about a blood job jacket.
Just killed.
This guy married his wife and he married
in the country.
We're fucking.
It wasn't even legal to be married.
This guy is one step ahead of the game.
All he gives a fuck.
It's getting his dick suck.
He's 60 something.
You think stallone shooting shit.
This guy.
Oh,
bits lapse alone with his dick.
This guy shooting everything,
he's got kids every six months ago.
Fucks a new model.
How many kids?
Mick Jagger Guy.
I don't know how many kids.
You got to pull up a song.
It's called one more shot I think.
Hold on a second.
It's got that on the get this band from
Youtube.
Nobody.
Nobody's slung.
Listen will chamberlain.
He fucked over 100 or whatever thousand
women,
but I believe nobody fuck more women
than Sinatra and Mick Jagger like that.
That we can only play one little excerpt
of it.
Not even like a little really damn
youtube.
That's why we need to work something out
with Youtube.
Youtube.
Hook us up with the new stones is good.
Not Bad man.
At least like a song,
but I don't know what.
No more stones.
The stones are the biggest business
merger ever released.
Six old songs and two new ones and they
bang it out for another 1995.
Dude.
Um,
when he came back or when it was like,
what is it?
Like 90,
89,
89 90.
They had like one big hit again.
What was that one big hat they had?
Okay,
so 81 was shattered and all that and
then after that it was the other one.
They took some time off and the came
back.
Neighbors not that out that it kept
going.
You guys like Bruce Springsteen?
No,
thank God that I'm from Jersey.
I want to stop that motherfucker too.
Yeah,
I like some brief.
I liked the first.
I ain't gonna lie.
I like 10th avenue freeze out.
I like a darkness on the edge of town,
but after that,
born in the USA with a pe shirt,
him jumping up and down casually tracks.
Fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Out The ball on what the fuck.
Well that's kind of for our show.
I don't give up after two hours I got to
get out of it was I'm fine.
He's like the special people on the east
coast that really emotionals songwriting
some great fucking songs.
Thunder road.
That is.
But this is what happens.
What happens is when a guy gets like
super famous,
it's really hard to keep up that
struggle and so you sort of become at
least a partial parody of yourself.
Have you seen them lately?
Them that fucked up at night.
This is a fucking marine is beautiful.
He gets on my last bid.
If the guy to me still,
he was going to run.
Man.
I love all that shit,
but enough already take them in time and
they told him he comes out.
What doing.
He gets on my last fucking type dude.
Anyway,
motherfucker.
And by Jovi,
Bon Jovi,
Jovi 87.
Slippery when wet boy dead or alive.
You guys are talking shit because born
to run is a thousand times better than
any of those songs.
So to run this tremendous,
tremendous trouble.
Bruce Sprint.
But I'll tell you what,
bruce springsteen,
when he had that,
the divorce,
then he came out with some jamming music
man because he like felt like really
like broken hearted over this.
You know him and this chick break it up.
So he came up with that brilliant.
The Sky Song.
That's a great fucking song.
That is a great fucking song.
He came back with some strong shit after
that chick crushed them.
Little girl.
We can manage it.
No one would ever make that song today.
Hey,
little girl.
Is Your Daddy home?
I had a bad desire.
What this?
Who the fuck would make that song today?
Couldn't do that song in the age of the
Internet.
They would crucify you.
They would go after you did the fake
Rick Ross last reebok as a sponsor.
Did you hear about that?
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's so ridiculous.
Sacred for us.
Made a some rhetoric about rape.
Dosing them with molly.
Put Molly in their drink it.
You didn't even know it.
You know something along those lines and
banging asleep.
Why would I ever have the desire to
Malia check or give it chicken roofing?
I'm a dirty animal.
Because you got game son.
No,
that's true.
I would have to check if you want to eat
a roofie.
I had like,
I had this little Jew than both of us.
She will need roofs on Sundays with me
and we freak.
She wouldn't let me fucking beat her ass
and 69.
It was wild,
but she know she had like a boyfriend
that was in the navy or something.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And she kept hope alive.
Uh,
we'd go out,
we'd have roofing.
We split a roofie because she liked them
too.
We had to go to the legal road right at
the corner.
It was like a,
it was like an industrial park of that.
Some dude like sheet rock.
Sheet rock is sheet metal and he sold
roofie.
She drove me up there.
A couple of roofers.
We popped on the Lord's Day.
We split the fucking roof.
We'd go have a couple of Margarita and
talk about bad Karma,
man.
You're selling roofing.
It's just here.
Go ahead and do it.
But I was responsible with the roof,
like,
no,
I couldn't.
I'm saying the guy who was selling
couldn't imagine doing that to a check.
It's not.
I'll work hard for it.
I'll take it home with an eight ball and
then switch it up on you and give you
aspects them.
You Suck my Dick.
You know what,
I'll run you through the fucking rules.
Egyptians don't give a fuck,
but I can't see that.
I can never see root sweetie.
You,
Joey.
I'm telling you dog.
I think rape is wrong.
I'm just saying,
I just think it's wrong.
I mean,
you know,
I can't believe you do it.
Why can't even watch law and order Svu.
I love law and order that I can't watch
it as 10 minutes on camera.
Watch this shit.
Yeah,
that's your,
your,
you know,
we all know that happens after a while
when you know that a certain amount of
violent crime takes place.
Then you watch him like bodies on TV.
Like I was watching it the other night.
It was at the airport and in the middle
of the airport there they're playing
this uh,
one of those shows like law and order
Svu or something like that.
And I'm,
I'm,
I'm seeing like,
like a body,
you know,
and um,
um,
I don't know if it was a commercial,
I don't know what the fuck it was,
but I was like,
well that's pretty graphic.
Like who?
Who wants to see that?
Like who wants to see that now that I'm
thinking about it was in an airport or
is it in a store?
I think it was a store either way.
The the,
the,
the important thing is that like seeing
those,
those images on those shows where
they're repeating over and over and over
again.
They have always liked graphic images of
bodies and pulling things out of bodies
and it's like it's pretty intense that
you're.
You're taking that stuff into your
psyche.
You're taking that stuff into your,
your bank of experiences.
I don't like sexual stuff on television
early.
He believed that the girls making out or
let's say I'm watching Diane Sawyer and
have like a condom commercial.
I'll fucking lose my mind.
A condom commercial will bother you.
Oh,
it's a little pond.
Really destroyed tampon commercial.
I want to choke myself and my wife was
in the room like your rants in the room
with some older woman.
I was a kid,
a Kotex commercial.
I would sit down and look fucking
straight ahead.
Dog.
I never get so embarrassed in my life.
I don't want them to ask me if I know
and I don't want to fuck the.
No.
The blood comes out.
Yes.
What
and what you pull up there.
That's got nothing to do with me.
I'm just straight up.
Don't even bring it up.
You know there's some women that cute.
Yeah,
they think it's cute.
Like hold on.
I gotta go.
We gotta a Tampon.
Listen,
I don't want to know.
I don't want to love your bleed.
You've ruined everything for me and I
don't want to know.
That's a really volume at.
That bothers me.
The sight of blood.
No,
no,
no.
I think decided talking about that.
You fucking pussies bleeding around me.
That's what I fucking hate when even
when they haven't that purse.
I got sick to my stomach.
I don't want to see a fucking tampon.
I don't want to fucking see a Tampon at
all.
Alright.
When I'm watching TV and a tampon
commercial comes up.
Even when I'm by myself,
I feel creepy.
That's so weird.
Calm and commercials.
That new commercial with the chicken
head popping out on the fucking thing.
Would you put on your finger,
have you seen that commercial chicken
with the creepy finger try know this is
great to relieve stress.
You know what meant?
I don't want to know about that shit.
What the fuck is that?
The Zombie.
Oh my God.
What is that?
Is was to put that away.
That's broken.
That one's broken.
That is just that.
Don't even get that one fixed this day.
Anything bacterial sprays,
anything bad.
General and television like 10:00
drives me up a fucking.
I've never had a period problem.
Oh,
I'll never had my own period.
Well I have my own period every now and
then,
but I've never had a like a period
problem.
Like a problem with the girls,
period.
No,
it doesn't bother me at all.
I told you the one I had to his day and
it was fucked up because my mother had
just died and it was the first time a
chick called me like that was my first
booty call level.
I had dated this girl before.
She was a cheerleader at Franklin
school.
I played hoops at Mckinley and we had
messed around a little bit.
Not really sex,
I don't remember Joe.
I think I sucked at Teddy's.
I knew a brother,
you know what I'm saying?
Like we were in grammar school,
high school and I had sucked attendees
or something.
I have to like a dance or something and
after my mother died I was home for a
week and this lady was taking care of me
and I get this call one night and it's
just chicken.
She goes,
you know,
you want to get together.
I was feeling bad,
you know,
I didn't know.
She just told me a little lottery pussy,
like my little funeral pussy out of a
God funeral.
Pushy.
But it exists,
you know funeral pussy.
Yeah.
Like after somebody dies in your family,
some chick causing such a dick.
Really bad like that.
Like a,
maybe like a,
like a women that hang out at comedy
clubs and these,
I call them groupies.
They have sex with Pete.
After somebody dies,
I'm serious.
But I knew her.
She probably just called me out of the
kindness of my heart that make me feel
well.
So I walked from 38th street,
the 46,
grabbed this bitch and walked back to my
house on 38th street.
I'm all fucking hole and up.
We start to take a fan.
So I pop up panties off and the Kotex
Pussy,
it's like a tongue.
One of those fucking haunted houses,
right.
This and I just sat there frozen like I
had never seen that before.
I had never smelled that before.
I had never been around anything like
that.
My mother had just died.
That was traumatic enough.
This was just over the fucking woman
still alive today.
Till this day,
I don't even look on facebook because I
might kill her because she fucked me up.
Joe Rogan fucked me up.
I told her to put her pants on.
I remember walking home the whole time.
I wanted to know how to control myself.
Till this day I think about that
motherfucker because she thought,
I don't know.
That's the first time.
Haven't seen a woman with her period.
And the last I made a fucking point.
That's so funny.
If I'm.
I don't care how old I am,
if I'm in a bar,
I got a bag of coke and somewhere along
the light that chick says she got her
period.
That's where the conversation and it
ends.
There's no more talking.
They used to have this freak.
They used to be this chick.
I used to mess around with Hollywood and
I knew her cycle.
She would have her periods,
the 20th to the 25th.
I wouldn't answer her calls.
Those five nights dog like six or seven
nights just to make sure everything
cleared and she never figured out.
To this day,
she's never have.
I wouldn't bring.
I'm going to waste cocoa pussy.
Fuck it.
I'll by myself and Jack,
but it doesn't.
It's still feel good.
It just.
The way it looks.
You don't like the way it looks.
I like it.
There's blood.
Is that bad enough for you?
That's fucking blood.
It's not bad enough for you right there
that you'll fucking blood.
No matter what you're doing.
You're fucking blood.
I know you like it.
I know Redmond for this tiny little
gravy comes out.
I.
No,
you send them a bitch.
That's the problem is you don't want to
look the bloods on the Tampon because
that's blood that was came out a month
ago or whatever.
It is.
Not a our or whatever it is.
It's all dried up and coagulated 93.
Yes.
Remember in Boston.
That was.
I never did that get know.
That happened after I left,
so it was a Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Open mic.
She did the weekend.
Thursday was headline when he did the
weekend and then you stayed the week and
during the week I would do Monday,
faneuil hall,
Tuesday some room and fucking quincy,
Thursday wooster and then I go back to
the ACO ACO or whatever,
but the point of the story is one Sunday
at that place I met.
I had met her before the open mic girl
was in the navy,
the hotels at club 56 is right next door
and she's like,
I'm Kinda tipsy and I kind of liked and
she had a crush on me.
We started swapping sprint.
We went next door.
That was the first time I was involved
in one of those dark light swapping,
spit things.
Hit somebody in the dark.
We were all over the place on the bag
and I remember my pants came off,
her shirt came off and I'm giving this
chicken stabbing,
but this chick's pussy was fucking wet
as fuck and I'm banging this like a
soldier in these days.
I had stamina.
It's like 98.
I was a savage before I got before the
belt and Doug,
I turned the light on and it was blood
everywhere.
Yeah.
See if felt good.
Right.
It didn't feel fucking good at all.
I knew something wasn't right.
I fucked up in the salty.
Something that's smoked,
something in the fuck.
That's probably you motherfucker.
I'm on fire.
No,
no,
no.
I'm a water.
Do it.
You know,
I like water.
When I go home now I'll take a fucking
shower before I go do comedy.
I'll take a shower,
I take a shower before I go to the gym.
That's how fucking clean I am.
I've always felt bad when checks can
feel bad about it.
No,
I would never call somebody a blade.
Doesn't matter.
I don't even get involved.
It bothers the fuck.
I just read whatever.
Oh No,
no,
it's not.
No one's getting hurt and she's fine.
A lot of times there are extra horny to
five times girls on their periods or if
you don't mind,
it doesn't bother me.
I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
What am I saying?
Shit.
I think it feels better.
And you change the sheets right after we
shut down a towel.
You Shit to worry about in this life.
I don't think that's one of them ever.
Period.
We.
You make Chicsville bad man.
No,
I'm not trying to make nobody feel bad.
Listen,
some people don't like snakes.
Snakes.
I'm like,
how are you equating snakes to have
girls?
Period?
Because I'm saying fucking same thing.
Fucking consume your soul.
So it's right there.
I spell it out for you.
Listen to your pussy.
Snake,
Adam and eve.
Not everybody likes the same things in
life.
You know,
people know if you don't,
if you can't handle it and your wife,
people don't like.
Oh yeah,
no doubt.
I just don't like that.
Some just don't like fat guy.
So when I bought some checks to,
you know,
some people don't like,
I just never liked it with a member of
the time you realized it was probably
like in your early twenties or whatever,
that some girls not only would light,
they want you to come in their mouth and
other girls get mad if you come in their
mouth.
Like,
like this is a,
there's a,
there's a different thing.
There's a very different response here.
Yeah.
You know,
like some girls will say don't come in
my mouth and you're like,
oh,
okay.
And then other girls in my mouth like,
Whoa,
for real.
Like is she,
does she really want that?
She tried to trick me like what is it?
I think the girl that after you fuck
her,
she always wants to take a little taste
of it.
Like almost like every single day.
That's a dirty bitch that once a year on
Pussy.
But she's too lazy to work out stretch.
She's too lazy,
lazy to become one of those.
What are those contortionists?
That's what that is.
She just likes the taste.
The worst is when you're eating out a
girl and she is on her period and he
don't realize it until the next day and
you see like the dried blood all over
your face and you go to a store and it's
like a clot in her too.
I think that's the alcohol and drug
problem.
Really just how the fuck you not knowing
what's going on.
You're eating.
This girl tastes like a bag of pennies.
Like fuck is going on here.
It was really,
really hot looking like I like all that
shit over blood.
Blood from fucking vampires.
How many fucking.
And
by the way,
the original vampire think about it.
If you really think about blade set this
motherfucking old.
He's out.
Hopefully it'll make blades nine.
Yeah.
And for anybody who thinks I have a
problem with that guy and I never had a
problem with that guy.
There was supposedly an MMA fight.
They were trying.
It sounds like bullshit.
And other talk about sleep pipes.
Yeah.
With Wesley Snipes it was not my idea
and I didn't.
I didn't,
you know,
I didn't have any animosity towards her
car at all.
How much time do you did?
Three years.
Three.
You have three fucking years,
man.
I just for the fucking wheel and not
only that,
he was willing to pay.
They were like,
Ooh,
doesn't matter.
You go in,
you're going to jail.
Like he admitted that he made a mistake,
tried to pay them off,
and they're like,
no,
you have to do time.
You have to do time.
They put him in jail for three years.
You can't just the government,
whether you,
especially if you're in a position of
prominence,
like a giant movie star like that.
If you run around saying that you're not
going to pay taxes that can fuck up
everything and they have to make an
example of you.
It's almost like they have to,
you know,
because there's a lot of people out
there that will argue about the
constitutional legality of this and
that.
And the reality is everybody's paying
you gotta pay you.
No,
it doesn't.
No one wrote it down in 17.
Seventy six.
Okay,
but it's 2013.
The reality of this situation is that
everybody's paying and these people that
go,
you know,
we have found a clause here deep within
the constitution that clearly states
that what is going on is
unconstitutional,
unlawful,
and they would never have this brought
up in a court of law because if this was
exposed,
it would take down the very empire
itself.
And people go,
fuck,
I ain't paying taxes.
Let him come get me.
I'll start talking.
Shit.
I start telling them about how the tax
code is illegal and not even in the
constitution,
you know,
and they're like telling Leslie Leslie,
and next thing you know,
I don't know.
I don't know if it went down that way.
I'm just guessing I'm making shit up.
I don't mean to be me,
me of the guy.
But then next thing you know,
he bought into some guy's idea and
didn't pay taxes like willfully.
And so that was for like a couple of
years and when,
when they were going after him and like
they're trying to,
you know,
he,
he won,
won but didn't win.
He didn't lose.
He lost like the second most important
one,
but I think he was acquitted in the most
important one,
which was like a conspiracy or something
along those lines,
but he's still willfully avoided paying
taxes and so they put them away for
three solid years.
You know,
when you're 47 years old like he was,
that's,
that's a long chunk of the future of
your life,
you know?
How much more time do you have?
Do you have?
Who's the oldest person ever?
He's like 1:20
and so we got eight years left,
less,
less than 80 years and someone just
stole three.
They stole three and wanting to put you
in a cage because you didn't pay them.
That is like some of the most gangster
shit,
like any society can never pull on its
citizens.
If you don't give us a piece of what you
earn,
then we're going to put you in a cage.
It's not like a debt.
It's not like there's some money on the
ledger that has to be corrected and you
have to eventually re compensate us
until we're even.
No,
no.
We're going to lock you in a cage.
That's our solution when you get up.
Yeah,
you're still going to have to pay us.
Well,
that's a fairly,
and that's a fairly victimless crime if
you really think about it and the
greater spectrum of all the things that
goes wrong in this country.
That's a fairly victimless crime.
I mean,
absolutely it's a crime.
Absolutely.
People should have to contribute to the
fixing of the highways and paying police
officers and all that jazz,
but the idea that someone should be just
locked in a cage for that is kind of
crazy.
I mean,
there's people that don't get locked in
a cage for assault.
There's people that don't get locked in
a cage for much more horrible physical
things where there's actual real trauma
to an individual.
There's an actual victim and they don't
get locked in a cage for three years.
You said the reasons why?
Because they wanted to make an example
out of him as a person in his position.
You know,
you can't go to the government going and
paint that really can send tags down
there.
Fuck you.
Dave Koresh.
If you haven't learned when they want
their shit,
they get there,
fuck it don't matter the government or
your fucking constitution,
throw that shit out the fucking window
and I pity you for even believing that
if you fuck up baton up,
they're coming to get you.
My friend at this point like retracting
that is going to be met with furious
resistance and the idea that it's not as
as really silly.
It's almost like at a point in this
country where things are so weird that
it's almost like one of two things has
to happen.
Either there's some sort of
technological breakthrough that makes it
impossible align anymore and then from
now on,
everybody has to operate like 100
percent.
No bullshit.
It's either that when we get adapted to
that or some fucking walking dead Zombie
type situation where we have to reinvent
civilization because we just keep going.
The way we're going right now.
This is.
There's so many opportunities for us to
trip over our own decks.
Just this North Korea thing alone.
See what's going on with this crazy
motherfuckers just pointing rockets at
everybody and Saber rattling and saying,
what do they need?
They need food.
Do they need.
They need power,
electricity.
They need something.
Obviously this guy's doing something to
get some sort of attention and get some,
some people to calm him down.
How long can that guy be around for?
How long can you have?
India and Pakistan hate each other,
pointing nuclear arms at each other.
Right?
Right.
They're just like staring at each other,
you know?
How much longer can people do what
they're doing?
It's kind of weird.
It's like one of two things has to
happen.
Either we,
they've got to figure out some new
invention that lets people all realize
that we all have like there's
repercussions to everyone's actions,
positive and negative and everybody has
a stake and everything that happens all
over the world,
whether it's in the Congo or the
fucking.
The people that are getting run out of
the Brazilian rainforest because loggers
have moved in.
Those guys are douchebags like,
let's.
Let's be clear about that.
Like some people were living in tents.
Some guys want to steal their trees like
everybody needs to settle the fuck down.
We need to look at this globally and the
fact that like country shit can happen
in the Amazon and the Congo and all
these different spots while that happens
and we know about it will never be at
balance and it seems to me it's like
something has to happen that connects
everybody.
Whether it's a stage of evolution,
whether it's a slow progress of things
it's we're going through right now that
we're where people are getting upset at
things right now that they never got
upset before.
You know,
where people are sort of realizing that
there were much more connected than than
people have ever been before.
And if that doesn't like continue on
that trend when you've got things like
North Korea,
when you got things like what's going on
in the Congo and you've got really bad
spots in Afghanistan.
Really bad spots on Iraq and the world
is.
There's,
there's parts of the world right now
that are in the apocalypse.
They're right there.
The apocalypse exists and it's going on
right now and while we're all just
sitting here living our lives that's
taken place and we know it and because
we know it,
we always feel out of whack.
We always feel like if,
if the whole world got his shit
together,
if we
human beings figured out a way where no
one was fucking over anybody anywhere in
the world,
no one was murdered.
Anybody anywhere in the world,
no one was raped.
Anybody anywhere in the world that could
be possible.
If it's possible doing this room,
it's possible doing the whole country
too late.
I already raped the chairman.
Does that make sense or am I just too
stoned?
Go back to.
I know that we have had discussions
about your fears and you always said
that one of your biggest fears was
staying healthy when you got older.
You didn't want to really,
really get old,
you know,
and well,
I don't want my body to feel,
feel walking around with a failing body.
LemMe tell you something that petrifies
me more than anything.
You know,
nothing scares me.
I never wanted to go to jail after 45
through.
Yeah,
I know all these gangsters and Glorious
and they fucking glorifying them.
Biography.
You know what?
They died in the fucking hole.
I Know Gloria and Dynamo fucking hole
when you're 55 and above.
I tell you what,
and I knew this when I was 20 at the 55.
There's only one thing you should be
worried about your grandchildren and
your pension to be paid for and that
it's amazing that those creeps made it
that long and then when you see guys
like John Gotti and jail,
Sam in the bowl,
they let him out.
That doesn't show you how to jail.
Yeah,
but I mean they let him out.
Let him out when he was involved and
they knew he was involved in at least
like how many murders pointed but some
insane amount of murders and they let
him go because he gave them information
on God.
But the beauty is that 20,
30 years from now,
somebody's going to find the file on
Sammy the bull gravano and it's going.
It'd be one of the biggest smacks to the
American people that you've ever known.
Nobody really knew what really happened.
Nobody knew that the government wanted
it so bad they wanted him.
I don't give up.
Listen,
I don't give a fuck.
I want this guy that will do,
will he killed 80 people.
Fucking there were Italian.
They got what they deserved.
Fuck them and their mother.
That's the thinking,
you know,
and,
and what people don't know is that Sammy
was brilliant.
The sense that he was the first one.
That was the first one to wrap what he
did to the government was brilliant.
The government knew.
I told you that there's the stories that
the government was collecting his loan
shark payments.
When he went away,
he went into the system,
got out,
and then that's when it really blew up
in their face because all these people
started going and testifying saying,
I would never lie.
I sold drugs.
Uh,
Sammy,
the bull of government go,
no,
you didn't.
Sammy never sold a drug in his life.
But after 50 people came in and said
yes,
they did.
The government finally said,
hey,
fucking lie,
and then that fucking idiot went on,
things will be out on the ice.
Man went on Hbo.
Now this third last interview,
he said he killed the cop and then Sammy
the bull gravano gave him the yard.
They went to the files.
They said they seen that he never copped
to that cop and lost them.
They had to move out with ecstasy ring
and they pulled him into jail and the
ice band mysteriously died to tell his
story to prosecute Sammy.
They took the ball and they put them in
Colorado in Tomahawk,
under the fucking prison,
under the prison.
So the government,
this is a king.
He never sees the light,
never sees light again,
but the government didn't give a fuck
when they cut the deal,
and that's not just with him.
They do this all the time,
but it's a different government.
That's the thing.
It's like the people that are in charge
today and not the people that put Sammy
the bull out on the street back during
the daytime,
most likely five fucking years.
He got for killing 20 people and they
got to take his money.
Yeah,
you got to take $10,000,000
and he got to.
They didn't care.
And then they put him in if he was in
Phoenix.
Right.
And then he didn't even try to go under
a fake name or something like that.
He told him to go fuck himself or he
told him to come and get them.
That's how crazy.
That little mother,
five foot five training with Teddy
Atlas.
Five days a week.
She is the ball default.
Fuck.
Did you see him before?
Huge.
Did you see him when he got nailed?
He looks scary.
He was five,
five to something.
Who's a human bulldog?
He was,
you know.
And he was fighting every morning over
that with Daddy Alice.
That's the truth to the outlets was his
training.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was a scary time when you have like
real legit mafia criminals like
flaunting it and New York.
What about what's going on?
I ain't your shit about how they just,
you know,
I shouldn't say this,
how they,
they arrest the Arabs in New York and
try to flip the things on them and try
to get those terrorists case.
What are they doing?
I don't know.
We had a discussion about they take the
people that go and push,
they'd take Arabs and they go and push
them in on those terror groups.
Well they did that and then I gave the
guy,
I think it was Dallas,
they gave a guy a fake bomb and they uh,
they had um,
tried to detonate it when you tried to
detonate,
they're arrested for trying to detonate
a bomb.
Like,
like you gave them the bomb,
like,
you know,
and I mean that's so crazy.
The idea that they would be able to make
a fake bomb.
Get it to you.
Let's do this.
Let's do the compensation.
Okay sir,
my friend bumper,
you know I'm going to give it to you.
You're the bomb guy.
Well,
I think he thought he was dealing with a
terrorist organization.
He gets to know he was dealing with the
FBI.
He had some FBI guy,
who is his.
This,
my friend,
uh,
medicat is devil.
We're going to take it down.
You are in,
you are an important part of our
program.
This guy's an idiot.
He's like,
I'm an important part.
Finally something.
Anything.
What do I do?
Is that an offensive voice?
Offensive or stereotypical Arab type
dude voice?
What do I do?
I don't know.
So what do you think?
Uh,
how do you think it went down?
Said to him.
That's a good angle.
What do you think?
You said you take this and you put it
in.
When you come back,
we'll give you a badge and they probably
be like Mpi,
benching and everything.
The guys like you.
It shouldn't be $55,000
a year to start benching and God and
God,
that's only,
that's only going to be back.
That's so he planned ahead.
He was that type of person.
All the governments always two steps
ahead of you though.
I think the guy was probably like,
if I do
this,
you'll be my friend.
What are you plan a terrorist music.
That's music.
If it's,
you know,
a terrorist music.
Is that John Ashcroft song that's
fucking terrorist music?
No one's terrorism,
bro.
Subway Sandwich.
How is that?
Tara was thinking I was in Nashville,
you know,
across the street from Nashville.
It's a subway sandwich right there,
right.
I'll fucking coolest Nashville.
Xannies national am I fucking around and
it's nice people.
Cool.
Nashville's a attached was as a fucking
cool tap.
Yeah.
But I was looking at that stuff and I'm
like those motherfuckers.
So Turkey fucking Salami.
Turkey Salami,
right.
You know,
they do such bad shit.
I don't even give you a full foot.
Yeah.
Did you hear it?
See,
it looks like I knew it was fucking me.
When you get six inches,
that's when you know a ton of sense
because I worked on lumberyard for
fucking years.
Six inches more like what?
Second?
In short,
the whole foot longs.
I got it.
I fucking talk to sit at one time and
then they got mad.
They got food poisoning from the tuna.
The tune is bad and I got at one time.
I liked the tuna for years,
but I.
You can't say that I'm podcast,
we're gonna.
Get in trouble.
No,
I'm just telling me,
allegedly saying that someone should
sell the post office to a private
contractor to run it like dps and
thought what the fuck and this guy
written up.
The comedy store is what happens when we
take a few days up the health department
on that way right now.
I'm not going to store.
Yeah,
you got a problem.
He's in there with a fucking.
I want you to take a bus.
Patient Shit.
They arrest him as a girl enters into
that bathroom.
Security is hovering over the window
looking in.
You're such a fucking man.
You just fucked everybody who has a part
of that place.
Brian,
you really did.
You're a terrible mother fuckers for
years.
We're looking at something,
looking at pussy.
I can't even dream.
How can you be such a fucking thing?
You know?
I judge everybody by my actions.
At least discuss those.
Look in the fucking pool.
Ladies Pussy do a fucking thing.
And to even looking.
I mean,
I don't understand.
I really don't.
That's the thing about any open
institution,
whether it's a comedy store or a park
where kids hang out and you're going to
get going to get all kinds of people.
You're going to get real friendly people
and you get to get people that suck.
You know,
and at the comedy store,
you've got to have both of that too.
You know,
we've always had those few comedians
that would come around and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
you got a back up and move away and just
like they have bad mojo and they're all
upset that,
you know,
why am,
why am I on this time?
And Joey Diaz is on at this time,
this is bullshit.
And they stomp around.
You always get that right.
Always.
Always put the people put cameras,
have bathrooms other places.
I see it all the time.
I didn't Chuck Berry get in trouble for
doing that or the steak houses.
And so chuck Berry,
I believe,
got in trouble for doing that.
I should probably look that up,
putting the fucking tape in the backroom
and then go and what are you doing?
Excuse me,
go back.
At the end of the day and empty the
camera looking at people pissing.
Why are you asking me?
I don't know.
Because you went into all that shit out
because I can't say that.
I don't want to say the.
How dare you?
Well,
if you take a pee at Brian's house,
he's watched.
No,
I'm not just saying that.
Motherfuckers watching those iphone,
I gave him the banana bread.
I caught him with his phone off you
gotta he was taping somebody at the ice
house.
This motherfucker,
he got like eight cameras all around
this.
Oh this is so not true.
But I,
I get that I was talking to a comic that
we are all friends with a or,
and he's like,
I want to send you something because I
was talking about the maps website and
uh,
he,
he goes,
I have something to send you.
And he gives it and take it.
And it was like a two things have keys
like key chains and they're like the
little,
uh,
things for your car,
for the alarm.
And I'm like,
why is he sending me this car?
And I opened it up and it's a camera and
what you do is you put it on your key
chain and so then like when you're
somewhere like a massage parlor or
something like that,
you hit record and just put down your
keys and that records hd video.
He just sent it to me.
He's like,
oh,
trust me,
I have the greatest thing for you.
Okay,
I got it.
Totally wrong.
Story of Chuck Berry.
Chuck Barry did a lot of wacky shit,
but that's not one of them.
One of the things he did in 1959,
he was arrested out of the Mann Act that
he had sex with a 14 year old waitress
from which he transported over state
lines to work as a hat check girl at his
club.
Fourteen year old,
14 year old.
Which race he was convicted,
fined $5,000
and sentenced to five years in prison.
His appeal of the judge's comments and
the attitude were racist and prejudice
by the jury against them was upheld.
And the second trial was held in May and
June of 1961,
which resulted in barry being given a
three year prison sentence after another
appeal failed.
Barry served one year,
one and a half years in prison from
February of 1962 to October of 1963.
He pleaded guilty to tax evasion,
was sentenced to four months in prison,
a thousand hours of community service
doing benefit concerts in 1979.
And in 1990 he pleaded guilty to
misdemeanor possession of marijuana law.
The last one that got him for wheat,
they should've looked at as legend
going.
This guy's done enough time.
She's transferred.
He said,
listen,
maybe listen to not let me go to suck my
Dick.
But I got a job as a motherfucker had
checked.
14,
14 year old hat check girl.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Chuck Berry was a bad motherfucker,
you know,
that was a totally different time in the
world too.
But that's the racism that guy felt.
What about the gun?
I played the piano.
He fucked his cousin.
And so red band.
What's that?
What's?
Come on guys.
Who are you talking about that,
that,
that Jerry Lee Lewis?
Yeah.
He fucked his cousin.
And he might've,
uh,
the allegations were that at one point
in time that he killed his wife.
It wasn't,
it didn't.
He?
Uh,
he get in trouble.
That's what they call them.
The killer.
That was actually,
isn't it?
What's so funny?
He's so fucked up on edibles.
You can tell high right now,
but I didn't smoke pot for over a week.
You didn't?
I didn't swipe up for the show.
Now we're,
we're off the deep end.
Let me tell you something.
So this guy,
fuck this cuts.
Killed this.
Yeah.
Someone drown.
Like one of his wives drowned.
Yeah.
But you know,
she could have just drowned.
Man,
you know,
might not have been.
What?
Are you doing,
you guys slandering?
No,
no,
he was so crazy.
Jerry Lee Lewis was so fucking crazy
that him and chuck berry,
we're doing a gig together.
And uh,
Chuck Barry Played Piano too,
right?
I think so.
Yeah.
So was it,
was it was chuck Berry that he lifted
his piano on fire?
That liberace?
No,
no,
no.
That's a
didn't Jerry Lewis?
It was Jerry Lewis falsified,
but Jerry Lewis lit chuck Berry's piano
on fire.
I don't remember that.
I think he did.
I think.
I think he did and I think he said like,
follow that motherfucker like you lit
the piano on fire.
I'm pretty sure I need to pull that up
because maybe I'm just combining scenes
in movies.
Jerry Lee Lewis.
Chuck Barry.
No,
not.
He was crazy man.
Which one?
Jerry Lewis.
Jerry Lee Lewis was crazy.
He was crazy.
Yeah.
That guy was nuts.
He had a fight.
He got in a fistfight with Chuck Berry.
Yeah.
Jerry Lewis.
Jerry Lee Lewis.
Chuck Berry feud.
Yeah.
These were.
I mean,
think about these types of people.
these are wild motherfuckers.
Just Jerry.
Just just thinking Chuck Berry.
Thank you.
Get in a fight with a guy like Chuck
Perry.
He's doing time.
Does a year and a half in the pokey for
transport and the girl across state
lines.
Apparently he sinks of Asian.
Apparently caught the piano of fire.
Then walked off stage telling Barry,
follow that n word in order to.
Yeah,
to intention.
If he actually did say an inward fall,
that n word,
it was a sad time,
sad time
and that that whole lifestyle,
golden to prison and coming out.
Oh yeah.
I love Chinese food.
Too much walking around too much.
Fuck you.
Especially in the sixties,
especially the sixth.
Especially doing title give.
They all listen.
Anytime that you glorify on television,
that's bullshit.
You still want to see your family to be
65 and Olivia whole life and think that
you were a gangster and to get put in
jail when you're 50 and have to be 67 in
fucking prison.
Let's say nobody gonna rape you.
They beat you up.
Just the thought.
Just being
freedom removed and you see these idiots
on discovery channel.
Like when they do it was prison.
It shows them,
and I'm on the road,
I'll stay up late writing,
but I put that channel on and I watched
the interviews of these guys like,
yeah,
you know I did it.
What the fuck did you do?
You fucking pissed away a life.
Pissed away.
A fucking light.
You do two,
three years when you're 18,
that ain't shit.
Joe Rogan.
Anybody could do it.
Standing in the fucking head.
Did you hear about that guy that they
just arrested that was living in the
woods of Maine by himself?
He hadn't talked to another person in 30
years and he had been surviving all this
time by stealing things from
campgrounds.
Didn't talk to people for 30 fucking
years until the,
uh,
the police finally arrested him.
So he was basically like a fucking kid
and just disappeared.
He,
yeah,
27 years.
He lived in the woods for 27 years.
He didn't speak to another person.
He just lived in the woods,
snuck into camp grounds,
stole shit,
and went back to his camp.
And so they arrest this guy.
He's got this a spot and they have all
these pictures of it.
Um,
if you go to the Kennebec Journal,
Kj online.com,
Kennebec K and N,
b e c and e,
b e c k e n n e b e c.
it's a part of Maine where this guy was
a Kennebunk port,
right?
Where her,
that's where a Bush had his compound out
there,
his family,
the older Bush,
but this guy man was just live in like a
character in a movie by himself,
not talking to any human beings and then
in the middle of the night,
stealing people's shit.
Pretty nuts.
Rosters death on the fucking night with
the dog.
This is a really amazing man.
That's fucking crazy.
Especially in Maine.
Maine is unfucking.
Bearably cold in the winter.
It's really,
really cold.
New York is called,
is cold,
colder Maine as a motherfucker.
Is that feeling when you get out of your
car,
you just get.
It's a totally different kind of is show
what the inside of his heart look like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They got a video.
There's a video up there of this guy's
place.
It's got all things hanging.
You know,
everything's hanging from a wall even as
a clock that he's getting taped up to a
tree,
stole someone's clock,
like stole all this shit and just like
packed,
crowded into this weird sort of tent
that he has set up in the middle of the
main fucking all kinds of people.
Man,
no,
he lit fires and shit.
We were starting to see because of the
we can get a story like this online so
easily and read into it that you've
never had anything like this 20 years
and he never got these stories.
They didn't show it on 20 slash 20 or on
one of those.
You never really got like this sort of
an in depth look at wackiness and we're
getting it every day.
Every day there's like some new dude.
It gets caught doing something really
fucking weird and then you look at them
and you go,
who is this crazy fuck?
What's going on here?
And then you'll forget about them
because tomorrow it's a dude has got a
pet hippo that he rides around until it
eats them and then he'd go what a
fucking weighed them and then the next
day it's another story.
It's just,
it never ends.
The guy walks into home depot yesterday
and tried to cut his arm off here that I
walk into.
Home Depot picks up a saw and starts
hacking his fucking arm off God down to
the bone,
screaming hot,
fucking in cutting his arm.
They got down to the bone until they
stopped him.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Really?
Joe Diaz.
I'll stop and thinking about that for a
moment.
I kind of walks into home depot and saws
his own fucking arm off.
Can you imagine being in this shit?
Why you go in there just to get a gallon
of paint.
You got to put up with this fucking guy
now doing this.
It's just you.
You might be there in the wrong place.
Wrong time.
When that guy does that or does
something even nuttier that harms other
people,
you know,
I would like to find out what that guy
was on.
You know,
I would love to know what these guys.
Life Tail.
I guarantee life.
That's it.
They lost a mortgage.
They lost the house.
The wife left.
The kid is on drugs.
The other kid's a fucking moron.
God knows because a lot of that.
There's a lot of life going on,
man.
It's tough for people right now.
You know,
you really think about what's going on.
They got missiles pointed at us,
whatever the fuck,
listen,
if he launches them,
I'm sure United States and do what they
can and will will be fine.
It's just the thought that it's right
there.
It's right fucking there were about to
be part of this.
Everything will change everything.
You know,
what people don't realize who haven't
been over there like you and I,
we don't.
We don't realize what the actual
conditions are in that country.
And when you read about it,
it almost seems like fiction,
you know,
when you read about the slave camps and
people were born in the slum camps and
you know,
some of them escaped and they tell these
stories of like how weakened they let
people get and then they like literally
like people are eating rats and shit
trying to stay alive.
We have North Korea slave camps.
It's horrible.
Horrible Shit.
Why is that a slave camp?
Because I dunno man.
Well they vice.com
exposed that they have slave camps in
Siberia.
The North Koreans have a slave camp in
Siberia and the people in Siberia,
they don't even know that they're not in
North Korea.
They think they're in North Korea,
but really they're in a slave camp in
Siberia.
It's really fucking crazy.
And what would I can't wrap my head
around?
I don't think,
and I don't think either you can,
you,
is that these people are living like
Stalinist Russia.
They're living like a real communist
dictatorial sort of,
you know,
you big view of the world,
their idea of,
of life is they have dear leader.
You know when people didn't cry for dear
leader,
you don't want.
The guy died.
People didn't cry.
I got sentenced to six months in jail.
They sent some people to jail because
they didn't cry.
So people like if you ever see the video
of people crying,
it is the most ridiculous overproduced,
overactive nuttiness that you've ever
seen in your life.
It's people just terrified.
It's really sad to watch because these
people are terrified and
they're wandering around crying,
just wailing.
It's so fake looking.
It looks so fake,
but it's like they have to put on a show
that the government is so,
it's,
they're,
they're so controlled.
It's such a horrible dictatorship that
the,
if you're not crying for the Guy Dying,
they just throw you in a fucking cage.
Yeah.
The balance of power for whatever
reason,
people always want to get to that sort
of total dictatorial position.
Like even the guy who,
uh,
who was the overthrowing of the
government in Egypt,
the new people that came in were like
adults and I don't think the law should
apply to us and we're going to do.
And everybody was like,
what?
Like there was like riots in the street.
They're like,
well,
this is what we just got rid of.
Like you're trying to do exactly what
the government before you like.
I see where you're going with this.
He crazy fucks.
It's almost like a slave camp.
What is the purpose of a slave?
They're making them where they're
working.
They're making things,
whatever it is.
I mean,
North Korea has almost no money there.
They're unbelievably broke.
If you fly over North Korea at night,
the lights are out.
They shut their lights off at night,
whereas you go to South Korea,
looks like any other part of the world.
We see people's lights on.
North Korea doesn't even have enough
money to keep the lights on me.
It's a,
it's an uh,
it's terrible.
You can't run a country like that.
They're not going to profit.
They're not going to prosper.
Like the only way to have a really
strong economy is you have a lot to,
a lot of people that are trying to make
things happen.
Not just like the people that are in
charge and then their slaves.
You can't run it like that.
You know,
you can't run it where you,
the entire civilization is under your
heel because a strong man is going to
prosper.
A strong woman is going to prosper and
anybody that knows they're under the
heel of the government like that.
They're never going to prosper.
So the economy is never going to be
vital.
It's never going to be like no one's
going to be out there trying to make
shit happen and kick ass and take names
and you know,
and,
and keep the,
the economy energized.
They're fucking terrified.
They're terrified of jackbooted thugs
coming into the house and locking them
in a cage because they weren't fake
crying enough,
you know,
and it's 2013.
That's the funniest part about it.
So this is happening right now,
just like you and I are taking fucking
southwest to San Jose and having a good
time and fucking driving to Vegas and
waving at people at the gas station.
These fucking people in another part of
the world right now are living in a
horror movie.
Fucking amazing.
You imagine men living in a horror
movie.
I mean you,
you literally are living in Star Wars.
They might as well be stormtroopers.
That might as well be darth vader.
You really are.
That means they have nuclear power.
They have nuclear power and machine
guns,
tanks,
and they're all willing to walk in a
straight line without lifting the leg up
at the same time.
Which is scary for us when everybody
moves mindlessly in a unit together.
Left,
right,
left,
right.
That scares the shit out of us because
that means you're willing to do whatever
the fuck they tell you once they got you
marching like that left,
right,
left,
right?
Well,
you can't just walk in carrying guns.
How impressive is that?
Let me tell you something.
Just walk in carrying those guns and it
was going to shit their pants anyway,
but you're walking in with that.
The sergeant,
Sergeant Carlos.
What is that?
Yeah,
what is that?
You're letting people know that you've
got these motherfuckers under control
completely under control and you're
doing that while you're in this
nightmare of a dictatorial society.
It's got to be horrific to live over
there.
She rolled the dice.
Oh,
I was so pissed because I got to go.
So lucky.
So lucky [inaudible] one on one at 5:00
and pisses me the fuck off.
So there's no traffic like New York
traffic.
How bad is it?
God?
It's just like,
all right,
this dress,
it's very bad.
I read this.
I can't believe it will go over.
That's why I said to you,
the tunnels and bridges and getting into
the tunnels and bridges can be insanity.
Insanity.
It can be like,
okay,
this was not happening.
Like how long does this take?
It's craziness.
The amount of humans and by the way,
no one's driving.
Okay.
Everyone's taking cabs,
so if most of the people in the city are
taking cabs,
it's the rare few that are clogging it
up like this.
The amount of traffic does not need even
closely represent the amount of actual
humans.
Luckily because the amount of humans is
staggering,
but most of them are not taking cars.
I'm explaining something to you and 94,
I was doing comedy and I went back.
That was an open mic or I lived in New
Jersey.
I dated a girl on 15th and Ninth Avenue
by Honda of Manhattan.
Joe Rogan.
I'm telling you I could get into my car
to coordinate and be in Manhattan at 10
after eight.
You know me know how the fuck is.
I pick her up.
My show would be at nine in the New York
comedy club.
About three years ago.
I went into New York City,
I had to pick my buddy up at the bus
station.
I'd never seen anything like that while
I thought it was going to take me an
hour,
tops took me four fucking hours.
I'm not shocked.
I don't know that.
Then there's nothing I want to do that
anymore.
I want to go get a hotdog.
I take the bus and the train over,
but I'm either taking them are over.
Those days are done.
I was hanging out with Shane Smith from
vice.com
or right.
He lives in New York and he has this
view window that it's like mountains.
It doesn't even seem real.
His,
his view is like,
it's like you're looking at like
mountains.
They're mechanical mountains that people
create.
It's more beautiful even than the
mountains that the New York City skyline
is fucking staggering.
It's so impressive that it's almost
worth being there just to see it on a
regular basis because it really is like
a work of art just like the mountains
are.
You know,
the reason why people are willing to pay
for paintings and shit because it makes
you feel good when you see something bad
ass when you look at something,
something beautiful like this sculpture
that this gentleman sent me,
the Buddha for my tattoo that um,
I,
I love art.
I like looking at shit that someone
made,
you know,
I'd like,
I like things that are beautiful,
but the New York City skyline,
it's like one of the most beautiful
things you could see.
Like when that thing is all lit up and
the cars are moving,
you're like,
Whoa,
I've never seen a pain that makes me do
that.
I never see a painting.
I see a painting.
I go,
wow,
that's cool.
I like that.
Oh,
that's bad ass.
But I never see a pain that makes me sit
down and open my jaw and go,
whoa.
But the New York City skyline will make
you go,
Whoa,
and make you sit back.
If you look at it from one of those
dudes,
it's got some crazy building with a
giant window.
And like a lot of those people that have
those like 180 degree views like people
with like crazy cash and giant
apartments,
they're view is the greatest view in the
world.
The view is amazing.
Seeing all that,
that skyline,
those lights and the cars moving.
I totally get it now.
I totally get it.
They have to live in there.
That's the main thing.
Like I told you to live in New York is
live like John Lennon.
If you're living there,
you're like John Lennon.
It's not.
It's fucking tough.
That's tough place to live.
They've have to commute from Brooklyn to
Manhattan.
You know?
It's fucking tough.
Well,
John Lennon is a perfect example though.
Why?
What's crazy about it?
I'm dudes just waiting outside to where
he knows you live.
Some wacky dude that wants to shoot you.
You know what I mean?
That's a secured building.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
People know that you live in that
secured building and you're John Lennon.
I mean John Lennon was one of the most
famous human beings on the planet earth.
They didn't care if this guy's living in
this building too,
naughty way to live,
stacked on top,
everybody but God so beautiful.
And we were there and there was a
lightning storm broke out.
Fucking a man to be on the 40th floor of
a hotel and look out the window.
You see lightning dance across the sky.
It's like,
holy fuck.
This is one of the coolest shows you
could ever see.
It was amazing.
New York has stopped.
That really moves me.
You know what?
The terrorists dog subway sandwich
fucking.
They already got something up.
They already got that up.
They already got a meme up.
People would not friendly there though,
man.
That's,
that's the weird thing is the dealing
with that constant stress that went away
after nine slash 11,
after nine slash 11.
People were super friendly there for
awhile.
We filmed fear factor there and like
2002 I think.
And um,
when,
maybe it might've been 2003,
but everybody was so friendly.
It was,
it was really interesting.
It was like when we went there,
people were like,
you could noticeably see that there was
like an extra effort that people made to
be nice to people that felt it.
It was like a fountain in the air and I
remember thinking,
hmm,
how long will this last?
You know,
like this is a new change of the way
people are behaving in New York.
I want to.
How long it lasts.
It lasts a long time.
It lasted quite a few years before I
started feeling like it was back to
normal again.
This last trip back to normal.
Solely back.
Yeah.
People are.
They just some people.
I mean there's plenty of Nice folks in
New York just like this,
playing Nice folks everywhere.
We met a lot of Nice folks.
The funny thing is when I walk in New
York,
there's some stuff that just fucking
moves me.
It moves me because I remember coming
off from Cuba and walking in and being a
little kid.
I'm a walking down Broadway and seeing
the first wall poster to her secret
service.
That's a James Bond movie with in
between James Bond.
His name was George Lazenby.
He was in between Roger Moore,
I guess.
Really?
Yeah.
Look it up.
Diana Rigg Kojak was in the movie.
It's called our majesty's secret
service.
Came out in 1969,
maybe 68,
maybe 70.
How many James Bonds were there?
The new ones.
The best.
That guy is fucking bad ass.
Bad Ass.
He's the best.
He was.
He's good.
But Roger Moore's good to Roger Morris.
Good live and let live.
And let my Roger Moore can fuck with
Sean Connery and Roger are.
These are the men.
David Nivon was the first one.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Let's listen to this church.
This is crazy.
Barry Nelson was the first one in 1954.
Even before sean connery.
So Sean connery was 62 to 1971.
And again he came back,
don't call it a comeback and 83 took a
12 year hiatus and then came back with a
new wig.
And then there's David Nivon who fucks
David Nevon.
They tried David Nevon out in 67,
right?
That shit didn't work.
And then they tried George Lazenby and
tried that out in [inaudible] 69,
the movie.
And then there's another guy,
Christopher Kazen,
cazenove cazenove because yeah.
See it's,
it's,
it's Ca z e n o v e and then Roger Moore
from [inaudible] 73.
Which ones at Roger More live and let
die to.
Good question.
But do you remember Timothy Dalton and
Pierce Brosnan?
There was two duds in a row to like
fucking total duds out here,
man.
Like the same person.
It's probably Timothy Dalton was talking
shit.
And I love to.
We've got Pierce Brosnan on speed dial.
Bronson would probably be good,
but get out.
Fuck out of here at both those guys.
I can imagine those guys kicking
anybody's ass ever.
I imagine them getting hit and just
start crying.
But Daniel Craig,
I could see that guy kicking someone's
ass.
I totally 100 percent,
but I think he's the best one of all
time.
He's a beast.
He like,
he seems like a killer.
Like when I'm watching them,
it seems like the type of guy who would
be like a problem drinking womanizing,
trained killer.
Like it all came together in the most
realistic version of it,
but I had a lot of people said it
sucked,
man.
It's funny.
There's dude posted on the message board
that I go to.
How fucking everybody told them was the
best bond era is like,
holy shit was at a piece of garbage and
I was like,
man,
I didn't get that.
I thought it was.
It was Roger Moore's shotgun before you
fuck out of here.
I'm telling you dog live and let die.
Roger.
I'm telling you that that was a Rogan.
I was just puking the whole time.
He had his finger up your ass.
That's the whole thing about those guys.
That's what it means to be fucking James
Bond.
That's what it means.
That's right.
The Suave,
debonair,
finger up your ass.
He was a swab that I'm telling you.
I didn't think so either.
See,
I grew up on the saint when the saint
was popular when I moved here.
So it was the Saint Roger Moore.
The saint was a TV show with a circle
around his fucking.
That shit the fuck.
No,
no,
no.
That was the watch.
Roger Moore.
The is yet he has his own TV show.
Yeah.
He had a halo.
That was the commercial for that.
What's the name of the show?
The mentalist.
A mentalist.
Ain't.
Oh,
that is so funny.
I never a fucking show.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Tremendous.
But what was better?
That or the Danny bonaduce show.
Remember that?
Anybody listen bro.
I'm gonna.
Drop some shows on you that's going to
bust your fucking head.
I'm going to tell you some good shows
right now.
It takes a fucking thief were fucking
wagner.
How about the wild wild west?
It's on now.
Yeah.
I watched that for me in my head.
Blows up,
bro.
That was a fucking tremendous.
The wild bastards.
Yes.
What was that guy's name?
That was the curly haired Brunette
boost.
What's his name?
I'm like,
this battery off my shoulder.
Will Smith came back to play it right?
He played it later.
Another assault me place.
I'm not talking about black people in
the wild.
Wild West there,
right?
It was two white dudes.
The guy's name.
Remember the seventies?
That commercial knocked that battery off
my shoulder.
He,
he,
he tough shit.
Remember that series was 65 to 69,
which was the wild west TV series.
Sixty five to 69 and the guy was right.
It was Robert Conrad and his buddy Ross
Martin who get never get any credit,
man.
Ross got the shaft.
Nobody gets any credit.
Dammit.
That was a good show.
I didn't know it was only four years.
I used to love that show when I was a
little kid.
The wild,
wild west.
Don't please.
I remember that was w or the wild wild
west.
It takes a thief.
Those or channel nine shows that channel
11 shows where the honeymooners.
Y'All couple Sanford and son the
twilight zone.
So you had them all and.
But my Benny Hill was on war.
That was the beginning of my comedy
career watching.
Hell,
if you're not a fan,
I can't talk to you if some way you
don't look at me and go,
yeah,
but Joel,
you're a fucking animal tip was going to
pop out you.
She comes once a week.
Somebody showed that debt on television
didn't actually show a real tip,
bro.
They showed something or at least you
will go crazy.
You will go crazy.
Everybody in school knew the next day.
Everybody got to make sure that,
man,
I think you guys hallucinating.
I don't think they ever actually show.
He'd close.
They got pulled it out when you were 11.
You lose.
Your face gets red.
You get dizzy.
Yeah,
you would get sick.
Couldn't believe it's happening.
There's certain shows that were awesome
for kids.
You know that like if like I guess
that's how we're looking at things
today.
You know,
we look at shows that are terrible and
like what the fuck is watching us?
But like for a little kid they show it's
still be pretty bad ass,
but the biggest rush,
my biggest crush ever was with Alona
from good times.
In fact,
I still see that fine black bitch
distance like tyler,
you sexy motherfucker.
She goes on.
In fact you shouldn't buy lady.
And she's still banking with a guy.
Who was that?
The black chick from a good time.
Well known.
Another one that lives upstairs to the
check.
She was beautiful.
She still wasn't fucking knockout.
But then the other one died,
right?
Shirley and Shirley temple.
Was she from good time though?
She was from John One,
the one with a rerun.
Which one was that?
That was the one with rerun on it.
You know those fucking people.
You sure?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Shirley effort was on a
what's happening.
Right,
right,
right.
What happened?
What's happening?
Can't it kicking in as well?
What is kicking at me?
Bulking.
So when you look back on shows some,
some shells.
Fucking hang in there man.
So like all in the family still hangs in
there,
you know,
it still hangs in there.
Print songs.
Prince songs are still fucking bad at.
I was in the store and uh,
I want to be a lover.
Came on and I was like,
wow,
I haven't seen this is like 1980,
wherever the fuck it was 81 or something
like that.
And I was like,
this song is still bad.
Go.
I'm going to tell you what was on the
way up here.
You motherfuckers.
I was in a car,
I didn't give a fuck about traffic of
the Joe Rogan experience.
You don't want it as bad as the one
later on.
Oh,
a boom,
boom,
boom.
Oh yeah,
Yeah,
that's a great sign sign of the Times
time.
But it's a great song.
All that thing he was doing in vegas
where it was a like you would pay 500,
200 people at the,
at the Pearl.
I guess.
I'm not sure.
People all attack me like,
yeah,
he would do so a really small bank for a
lot of money.
$500.
But you got to call the songs.
Wow,
that's awesome.
And you would say,
you know,
I just,
I always look,
look,
kid rock to you might be some fucking
redneck.
Okay.
And I.
and he probably is and his uncle does
math or whatever,
but it doesn't really matter.
One thing about kid rock is he knows
music.
You know,
one thing about comedy is I may not be
the funniest guy in the world,
but I love watching old comedy to see
where I came from.
Jonathan.
Yeah.
Jonathan winters talking.
Why I,
I'm a big fucking a Bruce Guy and you
know,
Jackie gleason,
I love to watch that stuff and when I
talked to somebody and when you talk to
somebody you might not like something
about them,
but just the people they admire,
you understand where they come from.
We're talking about this earlier,
but if somebody sold you on twitter and
you go to that page and go,
I get it,
you know what I'm saying?
They were riding around with a wig on or
some shit.
I understand now why they repeated this
with the same thing with me with comics,
you know like what you all combined.
So I like to know what people like you,
we talk about x and your dad was
thinking about it because one of my
influences also was Lenny Clarke
believable telling you I love Lenny
Clark and he become a major star.
Whatever.
Yeah.
To me he was because he made me get off
my fucking ass.
I liked what he was doing onstage.
You know,
Lenny,
the other guy from Washington.
I like to.
There's a couple of guys from Boston I
really,
really fucking like that.
They might not be stars to you,
but they're stars to me.
I thought so,
you know?
Yeah.
There was a,
you know,
we came from an era.
There was a lot of great comics from
like the eighties and nineties,
like we were talking about Ira.
We don't get recognized today.
There was some guys that was,
there was some goddamn killers.
Teddy bears.
Teddy bears on is one.
It doesn't get nearly enough credit
because he tripped over his own
addictions in his life,
but that guy at times so was like one of
the best comics I've ever seen him
tell you something.
I listened to an old Hedberg out and I
had to stop and check myself when I
realized how bad I really was as a
fucking comment.
I was listening to him in the car,
the idea of the college challenge.
Nashville fucking what a great town.
Just try me.
I got a great hamburger.
The guy night this place.
Jimmy Kelly's.
You thinking about moving now?
I don't know.
That humidity got me.
It's hot.
It gets hot.
That's it guys.
That's the.
That's the,
that's the one in Nashville itself is
safe,
but
when I was there I was talking about how
you drive 50 miles in any direction and
you're in a Zombie movie and really it's
what it's like when you're driving
through the dark areas of Tennessee.
Like he can get through some weird
motherfuckers don't know dark.
I love what you athletic athletic.
That's my says,
but I went to a spot where my in laws
are from Myelin and all that.
What Mike?
He's from Trenton and all that shit.
Motherfuckers don't know nothing.
You know what nighttime is?
Yeah.
You have no idea.
Gentlemen outside the door and I saw the
wolves.
They just drew wolves everywhere to get
the deer population down,
but they kill them something else now
and every night and my inlaws got the
dog.
I tightened the fucking balcony.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And there's not one was yellow ones.
I always,
I think they did.
They brought them in to keep the deer
population populations not.
I mean that fucking amazing.
So monsters to eat the food.
This is what I'm saying.
So now that you know they killed
something else,
now all they were killing the rabbits.
Oh God.
Did we kill him?
The fucking rabbits.
So one night you could hear my dad.
I'm 50 yards them.
That's so crazy.
Fucking crazy.
So that was wild.
I liked that style of living.
But man,
let me tell you something.
Listen to me,
tell you something.
My friends to know that like I wanted a
cup of coffee one night.
I didn't want to bother nobody because
this time I usually stay at a hotel but
it's too far.
It's too fucking far from the house.
I mean they're out there.
Joe Out there,
right?
Just beautiful land is paid for.
Gorgeous.
But they're out there like that.
I was like,
Terry,
I'm thinking this place.
She goes,
you know,
you get a cup of coffee,
it's 40 minutes each way,
like 30 or something.
Thirty minutes and you but you don't
know where you're going.
So it's going to be 45.
Here's question.
What's
more healthy that or New York because I
don't know because sometimes sometimes I
think New York is more healthy,
but in being there just for over a
couple of days and comparing the pace of
certain places that I've been to like
boulder and then comparing it to New
York and dealing with the people and I
don't think,
I don't.
I can't say it's like New York people
are shitty people,
you know,
it's,
it's not at the percentage of the people
that I ran into was very,
very small that,
that were not nice,
but those you might not ever run into in
boulder.
You know what I'm saying?
It's that the possibility of like
rudeness was there in a way that isn't
in other spots.
So I gotta think about,
well,
why are people like that?
Like what is it?
What is it that causes people to be
rude?
Is it just,
there's too many of us?
What?
What is it?
I think that's part of it.
I really do.
I think there's a certain number of
people when you get stuck in a certain
amount of traffic and a certain amount
of lines and certain mental waiting,
a certain amount of frustration is not
worth it.
Everybody,
everybody just
right now at one time or another,
the voices got loud with somebody at
some point.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's the answer to why people are
rude.
The problem with us as we call it in New
York,
there's just so much.
I still have it.
I still have that time,
so I have.
I grew up in that mentality in me.
It's Lubbock.
I am.
I get it,
but I don't get it all the time.
I don't get somebody being mean to you
have the fucking belt.
There's a difference between route.
In fact,
there's some rootedness that you
appreciate.
You're like,
thank fucking God.
We've got more people like that around
to make this lady push a little bit.
You know what I'm saying?
But that there's another type that
rudeness I can't live with at this point
in my life and when I was younger I
confronted with confront it.
Now I don't confront them anymore,
but then on the other hand,
he got around New York.
People are more street smart.
They just are.
There's people that are hipper.
They they like,
like they just seem to be more on top of
things,
you know,
the less obsessed with Hollywood.
I think that's a really bad thing about
the area we live in.
Well,
that's good.
Worse.
That's what I ripped the worst over and
over and over again.
That in this area,
particularly with.
Listen,
this is very funny because I didn't
think about this.
I was onstage.
I dare you Brian.
I dare you to get a fucking parking
ticket and be 45 minutes late to court.
I,
Danny motherfuckers to be late to court
and Steve,
you don't get a bench warrant issued and
when you get there you have to Redo all
the paperwork.
Why this?
Lindsay Lohan always an hour late for
court.
This cute.
You know Michael Jackson showed up in
pajamas an our late for court as well,
and they try to be strict like Michael,
you know,
you're 46 minutes late for court.
Come with this fucking fact,
Cuban to court late one time and see
what happens after a half hour there.
Strategies to it.
Let's pretend you got a parking ticket,
a speeding ticket,
and you know the cop a lot of times is
the best strategy that my attorney in
Jersey would do.
He would always say,
tell the copy I show up and then he
would call and go Rogan's running late,
but he would tell the court clerks or
we'll never get to the judge so the
judge would issue a bench warrant fleet
and we wait for the cop to leave the
building.
Then we sneak around the back and we
just say,
you got caught in traffic.
They Redo your bench warrant.
There's no to testify in a speeding
ticket.
And they dropped the charges with the
That's old school.
That's uncle Joe.
He dropping knowledge on a motherfucker
right there,
but there's other situations where you
don't want to be late for court,
especially if you go for Rehab or
Michael Jackson molest butting heads.
That's why right now that that tells you
right there.
I've been to court before.
I day even bolder,
the nicest people in the world.
Get the court 10 minutes late.
They'll even let you in the fucking
door.
Once they close that door in boulder,
sorry,
go to the third floor.
That means they handcuff you and go
through the whole fucking thing all over
again.
It's like the idea that you can come to
a place and this is the place to go.
If you want to get famous,
this is the place and the whole like
entertainment industry,
so this is like the main hub of it.
You're going to get a lot of cool people
to look cool.
People that we know that all live here.
Look at how many friends we have that
all live here.
You've got a lot of God damn cool people
till you get people that have gotten
through the whole thing and sort of
figured it out and relaxed and settled
in and then you know,
became a.
understood how to,
how to,
how to work within the parameters of the
business without getting caught up in it
and becoming one of those weird last
Hollywood type people.
This is my beef and I think it's true of
before,
so two and a red band doesn't look at it
this way and this and I've always
thought about because I'm 50,
but uh,
I go for auditions,
which you don't,
and I see a little bit more of this
bullshit and I once saw girls,
maybe six years old that were adorable.
I walked into a room this big that was
packed,
but these two little girls that was six
decide that they're going to take 20 of
the head shots and put them all over the
floor.
Okay.
And I heard the one girl say some
tailored girls.
You got to move this one little girl
said my daddy's a director or something
like that.
Okay.
So this is my problem guys.
Me,
I'm a piece of shit.
I'll live anywhere.
Really want to raise a child here,
you know?
Uh,
I don't want.
This is probably the values of life here
are judged differently than what they
are in Chicago,
Boston.
And you might look down on that.
Some people might look down on that,
but I don't,
I never don't.
I don't know.
I think for us there's like,
first of all,
this is the only place where there's
like such a conglomeration of those
people,
so it's like if you live your whole life
and you never come in contact with them,
you know,
this is,
it can be kind of shocking when you're
around like a bunch of actors are a
bunch of Hollywood types,
but the one of the real problem is
there's not any other that's looked at
like that prominently here.
That's so overwhelming.
There's so many people that are involved
in it that kids like automatically sort
of gravitate towards it.
They like everybody wants to be famous,
they'll gravitate towards it.
Whereas in Denver,
who the fuck is going to be famous?
So you want to be famous.
That's a real God damn pipe dream.
If you live in Boston,
you know it's a real God damn pipe
dream.
But if you live in Hollywood,
it seems like it's attainable.
Oh my God.
We saw this guy at the mall and then we
were there.
We saw this and we went to an audition
and I saw Ben Affleck.
Oh,
you know,
just becomes,
it comes more of a focal point and
there's not enough other shit here.
Let me ask you something.
How come?
Have you ever seen any pictures of Joe
Rogan hate dude,
never.
I'll tell you later.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying why?
Because Joe does pop razzi pages.
Well suddenly that I don't do all that
shit.
No,
I understand.
I don't like to go to parties.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just saying even anywhere you
listen.
If you go to Laurel Canyon,
farmer's market with your family now on
Sunday varieties,
that 10,
15.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm calling you right now because I've
seen him.
I encountered a bunch of New York.
I'm not A.
I'm not saying nothing bad about pop
rocks.
He's like,
I'm just making a point.
If you want people taking pictures,
you people take motherfucking busy.
If you don't want to,
you don't want that.
People will not bother you.
Don't bother you.
People don't bother Adam Carolla the
people that are in the,
in the,
in the limelight want to be in the land.
Well,
there's a lot of folks that do things on
purpose for sure.
Just the other night that was.
I was talking to my friend the other day
who,
he's a popper I'd see,
and he's like,
uh,
you want to go to the lax tonight?
I'm like,
why are you guys well here?
I got Lindsay Logan's boarding pass.
She's flying in at 5:30
AM.
I'm like,
what?
Oh fuck.
I've watched the other day or read it.
I read it online about Jamie Presley.
Did you guys read that story about her
getting into a beef in Hollywood?
Because the chick stole.
This is hysterical.
So her assistant,
somebody stole her assistance purse,
right?
The jewelry you heard about?
No,
she went to Hollywood to get the
assistance purse back.
But the girl that had something in the
purse that lets you know that the pro,
you like a gps.
The GPS on the phone was in the purse
and they figured out it was pointed to
this bar where they're having the
celebrity stuff out.
So Jamie Presley showed up and yelled at
the girl,
but then it turned out that in that
purse with drugs,
I don't know.
So the cops showed up and then nobody
knows who the person was.
Like once they got there,
like,
no,
that ain't my bro.
You guys were just.
They got into a fight over the fucking
purse.
But once the cops got there,
they opened.
The person was like blow and steroids
in.
There is some shit like that.
Ain't no motherfucking person no more.
Ain't no fuck.
We don't even know what.
It's always a pleasure,
my friend.
Do you remember this?
You're mad TV on the Sopranos.
She told me every fucking show.
It's
funny.
You just pull it up.
I saw James Gandolfini walking around in
New York.
How big is he?
A big guy.
Big Guy.
I saw him in that movie.
Them softly.
It's actually pretty fucking good movie
man.
Isn't a good movie.
That's pretty fucking good movie.
I knew anything Brad Pitt,
but to other solid.
They killed that.
Fuck that.
I don't know why they killed it.
I enjoy that movie.
It was a good movie.
It was one of those under the radar.
Brad Pitt's a bad motherfucker.
Kendall feeney is a killer.
He's a killer.
I don't know if he's know what happens
in this country every day at 5:00
now what happens at 5:00,
they started the sopranos from scratch
at Hbo.
They brought them back because it was
just too overwhelming.
Hbo took them back from a and e and they
said it's all going to play him every
day and there are doing season one
watching them my and there was torture.
Torturous,
but not all the swears and all the bad
shit.
That Wasi episode,
the third episode of season,
when they take the power back,
when Jackie dies,
they go down.
That is one of the best written show of
off and gather.
The feeney was very.
I forgot how good he really was.
Everybody else was sub par.
He was,
he's amazing.
He fucking,
he plays a total psycho and it's killing
them softly and it's so fucking
unbelievable.
It's so believable.
Oh,
that's great.
They seen a period for that guy that did
district nine,
his next movie with Matt Damon in it.
Um,
no,
it's fucking amazing.
Uh,
you remember the name was it?
Yeah,
but it's takes place like 100 years in
the future in the trailer is so bad ass.
It looks amazing.
Well,
um,
I was in New York this past weekend for
the upfronts,
for Scifi,
for this new show that I'm doing that I
can now talk about that I don't get in
trouble called Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
But they got this new show called
defiance that's coming out.
That's a combination video game and
science fiction show.
Dude,
it looks insane.
It's this,
it's a huge,
huge,
huge project that the Scifi channel is
an undertaking.
And the SCIFI channel,
we're battlestar Galactica came from I
think so.
Was that the,
did they do Battlestar Galactica?
Battlestar Galactica was one of my
favorite fucking shows ever that,
that remake Battlestar Galactica.
It took till season two for Brian to
convince me that I should check it out.
It's fucking tremendous.
Twice,
like 54.
What is it?
This is that new movie.
It's caught and it has matt Damon in it.
And just look at that though.
Look at that right there.
That's fucking beautiful.
Yeah.
What Saifai that did battle star
Galactica,
like it's supposed to be a 21,
54,
I think like really long in the future.
And it's like Matt Damon's all buffing
it and said,
oh,
for my.
But if it's just like district nine,
oh my God,
look sick.
I know.
When is this coming out?
Uh,
August ninth.
Wow.
I need to get to a museum.
But yeah.
Whole.
Wow.
This looks incredible.
He upgrades his body.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You can say,
Hey,
if we want to break into the most
humbling place,
his body is like,
that Shit's drilled into his body.
Yeah.
He upgraded his body.
Holy Fuck.
You know that's coming.
Yeah.
So like some Mad Max type shit.
Dude.
When does this come out?
August night.
Oh,
this looks jodie foster.
Very district or any
except no aliens that we know of.
Reason.
Why do you say that?
You're just making shit up now.
I'm going to be looking for aliens.
Now I'm going to be all like hoping
there's an alien.
Looks bad ass though.
That looks pretty dope,
but I prefer aliens.
No,
if you're going to be all in the future
and shit,
I want to see something that's not real.
I want to see starship troopers.
I want see giant bug people.
I want to say like the movie alien,
like Sigourney Weaver,
alien.
That's the shit.
That's my shit.
Can I just pump a sacramento?
Sacramento next month?
Five,
three,
five,
four,
May 3rd and fourth.
We're gonna be in Sacramento with Tony
Hinchcliffe and Sam Tripoli.
And then San Francisco.
Sunday,
May 5th.
We're doing one show there.
Tickets are on sale right now.
And then tonight me and joy ideas are at
ice house,
uh,
with a couple of other guys
do.
And Joey will also be a flappers on
Tuesday for [inaudible] benefit.
And I'll be this dog and Brian and Ari
is going to be there as well.
And I'll be there.
Have you heard that?
The lineup.
It's sick.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And then Burke Christchurch to be there
and then it's really good
and it's all for um,
the uh,
the,
the aid of Tommy's dog.
He got a dog that got really,
really sick.
So they're uh,
they're putting the dog to,
you know,
hospital care and all this stuff and
across a lot of money.
So we're taking care of everybody.
Timing,
please come and support.
It's Tuesday at flappers.
Yes.
Um,
uh,
thanks everybody.
Thanks for all the,
the,
the powerful love out there from the
Internet.
That's why April 19th,
I'm in Miami.
You were in San Jose but you sold out
already.
So help me out.
April 19th.
Jack,
you're at the fillmore.
Yeah.
Fillmore to shows eight and 10:00.
Go to South Beach Comedy Festival.
Bill burrs that Thursday.
August there.
So men's Day.
It's a nice little fucking lineup.
I'm going in.
I'll be back here for 20 smoking dope
somewhere,
but make sure if you have west Palm Jews
come on down.
Fuck Fort Lauderdale Jews.
Come on down.
Cock suckers.
I did that Gig a couple of years ago
with Tom.
Being Tom Segura did it.
Is fucking fun to Miami Comedy Festival
is really fun when you start doing it
every year.
I couldn't do it this year though.
I was.
I had something booked already and
always really dynamite west Palm beach
to shoot a gun.
We had a great time for shows,
bing,
Bang,
boom.
Sold out 2,400
people and out of that good sets,
good energy.
Keep doing that one brand.
That's what you.
You know what else too?
It's like what's happening now is all
these clubs that we go to,
we're bringing our crowd so you're
getting all these really fun was fun.
Positive people.
No matter where we go,
we're getting them everywhere.
So Nashville was fucking out
outstanding.
That was outstanding.
That squad Nashville.
I want to give him all these debts.
Squad charges a fucking radio.
All you lifting,
you bad motherfuckers just please keep
it together on our behalf.
Don't let any government agents
infiltrate and start to fuck up the
group already.
There's already the government.
They're trying to find out where the
weed is.
Once we will become legal,
they have nothing to talk about us for.
We're not really looking overthrow
anything.
Just relax.
Government agents and I'm in Austin to
next month having a good time.
I can't wait to go eat food.
Beautiful.
I Love Boston,
Arizona.
I'm headed to a seminar in Austin for
the TV show.
I got to go talk to some doctors about
some wacky disease when you come back,
your beautiful baby and then we got New
Brunswick.
Brunswick basically sold out.
Now I don't think there's any tickets
available for our.
Show me who's on that card and not have
it in front of me,
but I'll pull it up and you second
second.
What's up?
B round?
Taking a second.
Let's thank our sponsors like to think a
stamps.com.
You bad motherfuckers again,
if you have ever ordered any of those
desk squad dot t v t shirts from Brian
Redman.
All of those came from the software that
Brian uses from stamps.com.
It is an excellent service.
You don't have to go to the post office
ever again.
You can sit at home,
you use their software,
you measure it,
they give you.
If you use the code word Jr,
he.
There's a microphone.
If you click it in the upper right hand
corner and in the code named Jerry,
that's jus revenue experienced ladies.
Gentlemen,
you get a free digital scale and uh,
it's a wizard $110.
Offer $110 bonus offer at $55 up to $55.
Free Postage and digital scale.
It's a,
it's a dope service if you have a small
business and it's really like the best
way to go.
I mean don't torture yourself.
Use it.
Post Office works awesome.
Stamps.com.
Get it Hala are.
Use the code a thanks to onnit.com.
That's o n n I t a.
use the codename Rogan.
Save yourself 10 percent of any and all
supplements.
Uh,
thanks.
Also to retain.
If you go to a Rogan.ting.com
and enter in a.
You don't have to do shit.
Just go to [inaudible] dot ting.com.
Enter in your information and get $25
credit towards either a phone or a
device.
That is it for this week because a,
I've been doing that,
that TV show thing.
I've been busy so we won't be back until
Monday.
But on Monday we're starting back again
with a Steven Rinella and Brian Cowen.
And Tuesday Greg Fitzsimmons and mostly.
Yeah,
and most likely we'll do one more
podcast next as well.
And
to answer Joey Diaz,
I'm going to the UFC and I'm looking for
the schedule of upcoming events.
Let's see what we got here.
We got baby.
Let's see.
Red Band tonight.
Tickets still available?
Tickets.com.
And don't forget Miami.
Next Friday.
Get your shit together and bring all
blow.
Just refa rolling papers.
Edibles,
Bazookas Cuban sandwiches.
Does shit like that.
Yeah.
Let's see what the fight card is around.
This is a.
we're looking at the Jones versus Sonnen
fight card.
God Damn my Internet sucks any day.
Now Ladies and gentlemen will be fixed.
Alan belcher versus Michael Bisping.
That's okay.
Oh fucking shit.
That's a great fucking thing.
How about this?
You ready for this Roy?
Big Country Nelson versus check Congo
strapped the fucking sun.
That could get crazy.
Big country.
And Chuck Congo.
God Damn.
That's going to be a great fight.
Vinny Magalhaes and Phil Davis.
I fucking love it.
I love that fight.
Has been asking for that fight to you
know vinny magallanes when he left the
ultimate fighter.
And went over to [inaudible] global and
kicked ass and became their champion and
just really develop some striking to go
along with his Jujitsu,
which is some of the best in the fucking
world.
And Phil Davis is a beast man.
He's a wicked wrestler.
Comes from alliance,
a great camp.
That's a great fucking fight.
Jim Miller versus Ryan healing.
That's a great fight.
God Damn Son.
There's this great fight.
The undercard tube.
I'm that guy.
Uh,
what else we got here?
Oh,
over in St.
Prue.
Yeah,
he's,
he's finally fighting.
He's on the fx fight.
He's the dude who was a beast.
He was doing really well over in
strikeforce.
And finally,
uh,
he's in the UFC as well.
There's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
10,
11 fights that card.
So it's,
it's excellent.
And there's a girl fight too.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Uh,
Sarah Mcmahon and Sheila gaff.
This is going to be wild man.
Having all these chick fights inside the
octagon.
It's gonna be.
It's gonna be very interesting.
Misha tate is fighting soon too.
And when Misha tate fights,
that's going to be really fucking
interesting because she's the one who's
going to fight Ronda Rousey.
They're going to compete against each
other on the ultimate fighter.
Got Old.
I like me fan.
She's awesome.
She's a very,
very cool person.
I loved it as her boyfriend,
Brian Caraway.
He's cool as fuck too.
All right.
That's it for this week.
Did we say thank you to stamps.com?
Yes.
Thank you.
That's it.
I love all you motherfuckers.
You savages on twitter.
Die All you people out there making it
in the free world rocking.
Don't worry about confederate flags.
Bill Leonard Skinner Fan.
There'll be scared.
Don't be scared.
Ll Cool J.
Keep it together.
You fucking freaks.
We love the shit out of you.
We appreciate you very much.
Joey,
I love you guys from the bottom of my
heart.
Stay black,
brown,
red brand weekend.
I left Miami bitches.
We are.
We love all you freaks.
We'll see you soon.
Right.